hello freak bitches welcome back once
again mad flavors here and he's got his
fucking reading glasses on so you know
shit is about to get serious this
episode of the Joe Rogan podcast is
brought to I said it again it's brought
to you by naturebox naturebox one of my
favorite new sponsors they make some
goddamn delicious shit and send it
directly to you for free if you're one
of those people that works in an office
and you get annoyed of the fact that you
don't have good LD snacks to eat
that's delicious that you don't feel
guilty about eating and you know the
vending machines filled with crap and
it's hard to fuckin go to the store and
buy shit and think okay these are my
snacks for work way easier to have
naturebox deliver it and naturebox and
deliver stuff that is with zero trans
fats zero high fructose corn syrup
nothing artificial no artificial
sweeteners they have like really healthy
options and then they have shit like
pretzels but which are very yummy very
yummy hot FIGS
oh yeah good cocoa almonds have you had
that big apple pineapple fuck yeah black
and white granola is delicious they've
got endless stuff on there that you and
this nutritionist approved it's fucking
delicious did you get the sriracha
cashews yes I did did you get the step
by sea pistachio yes
you get stoned sometimes you're hungry
you're looking for something that's the
perfect fucking snack people yeah this
is one I you know naturebox can set you
up to if you have very specific dietary
requirements like low sugar or gluten
free really really delicious shit free
shipping anywhere in the u.s. naturebox
is busting the vending machines monopoly
on your midday hunger that's their
fucking line not mine
see the different try nature box right
right now I get 50% off your first box
by going to nature box calm
so for 50% off nature box.com
Rogan in joy you freaks cuz we do a
nature box is in fact the shit it's
really cool because they like any kind
of snacks they tell you right they're
like soy free dairy free they tell you
like it's really well put on their
website
and when you get it sent to your house
you don't even realize how easy that is
that sounds like five things just throw
in your and your cupboard and then you
have snacks the whole week instead of
like going to McDonald's or something
like that on the way home good shit
sorry you could find this stuff at the
grocery store with a fucking gonna find
sure watch it cashews yeah like they
have some excellent recipes that they've
concocted so I salute them
we're also brought to you by Tang
another podcast sponsor that I really
enjoy ting is a podcast come for a
podcast company podcast sponsor that
what they decided to do is make their
own cell phone company rent time on
Sprint but do it their way do it do it
their way with no early termination fees
no contracts just sell people service on
Sprint so you know you get anything
excellent network and give them for a
choice the best mobile phones available
through Android and iPhone leave that I
found out five on there and instead of
like the way you do it at most places if
you go to a one of the bigger name cell
phone companies what you're doing is
your rent sort of like leasing a phone
like if the phone cost two hundred bucks
its iPhone doesn't cost two hundred
bucks bitch an iPhone cost six hundred
bucks but you pay two hundred bucks and
then over the course of the years of
your contract you pay off the rest they
don't do it that way ting if it says two
hundred bucks
it's because it's two hundred bucks
that's it we're done here do you give
them two hundred bucks they give you a
phone that's a wrap like you see that
iPhone five they had two hundred sixty
bucks that's what it actually costs and
then that shit is yours and if you want
to leave you leave you want to come back
come on back nobody gives a fuck all
right what they're trying to do is sell
you an excellent cell phone service at a
reasonable price with reasonable rules
and they also have it set up so you only
pay for the minutes that you use if you
use one minute a month that's what you
pay for if you a hundred minutes a month
that's what you pay for
it's that's what's gonna happen in the
future because all these fucking goofy
rules where it's like you need to go
over a hundred and twenty minutes and
you got this fee because you got an
overage fee and all that nonsense can
you imagine if one of the big-name guys
did that they would ruin everybody
because all right oh yeah that makes a
lot of sense let's go to the this other
big-name place I think in the future
that's the only were they gonna do it I
really do I think ting is way ahead of
the curve they're also ahead of the
curve they had on their two-year
anniversary they just for no reason just
decided to slash all their prices
they're like we
better deals so we're gonna give better
deals to you guys all the prices on data
if you're like a heavy user a heavy
internet user especially the data prices
on ting are fantastic 98% of people
would save money with tang
98% that's real numbers I think the
other website statistics $21 is the
average monthly bill per device for 10
customers I know you paid more than 21
bucks go to Rogan tang comm and save an
additional 25 bucks of any of those new
delicious Android devices that's Rogan
ting calm we are also brought to you
last and foremost by on it oh and an IT
a human optimization website what we
sell it on it as all things that we have
found to improve you improve your mind
improve your endurance improve your mood
if we find things they prove to be good
if we look at the research and it makes
sense we post all that research along
with references all the stuff that we
sell whether it's the controversial
things like alpha brain and shroom tech
and new mood what you're dealing with
the Alpha brain and new mood you're
dealing with these things called
nootropics what nootropics are is
vitamins and nutrients that have been
shown to have a positive impact on
cognitive function it's very
controversial stuff if you you know you
google online you can find people that
say the vitamins are necessary and
they're bullshit they don't do anything
for you nutrients all you need is what
you get from your food do you know how
much fucking weird grasses and moss you
would have to eat to get some of the
nutrients in something like alpha brain
you're not gonna get it from your food
man like is it better to have a healthy
diet than just to eat a shitty diet and
take supplements i've
abso-fucking-lutely healthy diet is
number one it's the most important thing
but for optimization for optimization
meaning making your body and your brain
function at its very peak at its best
when you feel the smoothest the longest
the most often you can do that with
supplementation better than you can
without supplementation this is from
anecdotal evidence my personal evidence
would like my personal experience rather
and it's also from research all the
research available at on accom including
our own double-blind placebo studies
that we did on alpha brain we did one
showed positive results were doing a
much larger one now what we're trying to
do it honor is to sell you the shit that
we find
that works as far as strength and
fitness equipment the strengthen
conditioning equipment we sell like
kettlebells and battle ropes and weight
vast steel maces all these different
things are great for functional strength
no bullshit's no gimmicks no fat loss
nonsense if we find it it's got to work
before we sell it and we look into it
very very thoroughly we also have a 100%
money-back guarantee on any of the
supplements 90 90 days 30 pills the
first bottle of 30 pills 100% money-back
guarantee you don't even have to return
the product we're trying to sell you the
best shit we can find go to O n n IT use
the codeword Rogan and save 10% off any
and all supplements
alright you fucks mad flavor aka and
then you stay on a program with a
million of stuff every month
automatically to your house yes on the
first tremendous you can't be done you
get 20% off and to Rogan whatever in the
pocket and get the motherfucking 20% off
they deliver it to your house you could
put it on program you get you alpha
brain you're screwed track you could
rotate it because I talk to mr. Rios you
can rotate the stock
we're in so whatever you need don't send
it to you the first of the month you
have to sit then go back on the fucking
computer try for 90 days comes yeah the
get on it program has been very
successful tremendous go there catch a
freak on Joey Diaz is here the Joe Rogan
experience
mooom shall lock lock boom Joe we
motherfucking Diaz what's up my brother
violating state law you an electronic
cigarette in the house what am I gonna
do I have a question for you but I wat
it cuz I always I always have questions
for you I forget to talk to you about a
month ago somebody posted the mushrooms
the quadricep mushroom cordyceps
cordyceps there and shroom tech and they
had like what this mushroom looks like
and then 10 years and how it got fungi
and this is what it does the inside your
system that's all bullshit it does
inside your system like inside your body
what it does announce this shit look
there's a lot of mushrooms people eat on
a daily basis like fungus is a normal
part of people's diets you know when you
when you eat but if you eat shitake
mushrooms you're eating a fungus it's
reading something that's a fungus
you know your whole body's filled with
little growing organisms but no
cordyceps mushrooms not going to grow
inside your body and like make roots
great fucking plants and come on those
ads on Facebook they show like if you
eat quarter-cent mushrooms well there's
a bunch of different kinds of cordyceps
mushrooms to the there's two different
types in in shrimp export to different
types of course ups mushrooms now when
you do the shrimp export it's not that
you get height I don't get height now I
just feel it at the end like I'm like I
look at the clock I'm like well usually
I leave at this time when I got one more
yeah you get an extra round or two we
got one more yeah no bullshit me you
know what it came from came from these
high-altitude herders they were like
moving cattle around and they founded
these these when these animals would eat
these certain mushrooms they'd be
noticeable mostly more lively so they
realize like it's probably something to
do with oxygen production it's like I
guess if you go to certain places of the
world it makes sense that there's
certain foods that would be good that
grow in that to help you deal with
certain aspects of the environment
that's challenging you know like high
altitude you know it's like go to Denver
let's fucking go up the flight of stairs
like whoa that's like whenever they have
a UFC card in Denver I'm alright here we
go
fucking they had Ben Rothwell and Mark
Hunt two dudes not exactly known to be
triathletes good fight in Denver and it
was a crazy fight man just a ridiculous
crazy white report guys almost died they
don't both almost had heart attacks the
fighting of fifty five hundred feet
above sea level you weight 265 fuckin
pounds how much do you have to how long
before it says it says six weeks to
acclimate yeah what they say but I don't
thankful I talked to a guy who lived
there who was a triathlete and he told
me that he moved there for his training
yeah like there like a lot of those
endurance athletes moved there he was in
Boulder and he told me takes 3 years 3
full years before your body is like like
right the right how you are right now if
you're in Burbank boom right now Joey
Diaz you would have to get to be this
level of comfort with your breathing
environment and with the oxygen level in
the air it would take you approximately
three years to get a hundred percent but
you get pretty close within the first
five when those fighters go to Denver
how long they go two weeks
there's a lot of like debate on that
what they're thinking now is that what
you should do is not train at altitude
what they think now is that you should
train at sea level but then sleep at
altitude so if that's the case like you
don't have to go anywhere like BJ Penn
had one of those tents that he would set
up in his house and when he was would go
to bed at night he would sleep in this
oxygen tent and it was like it simulated
being at high altitude so that's what
guys are using now they're using these
tents it was funny because BJ set it up
and it goes it was really funny as you
said it up he goes he goes when I gotta
sleep in a tent someone's getting their
ass kicked he's setting up this fucking
plastic tent in his living room you know
it's a wild I was just in Utah in Salt
Lake City and also elevation yeah you
don't remember you just go out and do
something this BJ's sleeping in tent
back it up said Joey is that coming I
got it I got Anthony Gonzales who is he
I don't know he's just talking football
player oh yeah a lot of guys do this now
they sleep in these fucking tents I know
when they play football in Devon but
that's murder when people come and visit
they gotta fly in on Monday and they get
to practice the whole week the NFL does
you don't get do because you got to do
something just to acclimate you got a
ramp up for that shit you can't and you
should you should wrap up your your
training in your cardio beforehand
anyway just to deal with the fact that
you're gonna like this some guys I don't
have to do anything they're just in such
good shape they get up to Denver they're
they deal with it a little bit they feel
it a little bit but they're in such good
shape they can just push forward that's
amazing when you walk around the city of
Boulder per se and you walk around
you're there for six weeks and you'll
acclimate and everything or whatever
they say and you start getting used to
it and then you go skiing
hmm and that's what you really find
because there's a level on the mountains
that it's just brutal mm-hmm it's just
fucking brutal yelling 11,000 feet
here's the fucking crazy thing a lot of
people decide to eat up there and that's
when you're in trouble really
your body can't have that your body
can't handle no shit a little while up
it up down I'm talking I play 11,000 you
could ski down it that's fine we ski
then we get to the bottom we go up and
you get your momentum and your ski and
you get it's when people stop up there
and they hang out for an hour neat they
get out to to sickness I out the truth
you know the high altitude sickness it's
a motherfucker it's
being seasick really it's like being
seasick you just want to lay down it
makes sense man yeah cuz living at 8500
feet you like when you go up a flight of
stairs like any time we go for flight of
stairs you gotta go oh like I'm never I
never go up a flight of stairs and take
a big deep breath but in Boulder don't
take a big deep breath and you can
imagine that like if you go higher than
that go like 11,000 like 8,000 to 5,000
is a big difference so I gotta imagine
11 it's like some next-level next-level
shit and and it's crazy when you're up
there for a while you're tired like you
don't have to do anything just talk to
people up there it just puts your body
through something because the first time
I moved to Colorado I didn't go to
Boulder I went to Aspen and all I felt
like doing was sleeping and I was 18 I'm
gonna sleep now at 50 right teen I
didn't fucking sleep we slept a man for
like three weeks all I could do is
fucking sleep I couldn't take him em all
wow it was just that heavy I passed out
up there smoking pot the first day I
took a big old bong hit picking me up
off the fucking floor first day and
asked for a Sunday more afternoon I went
to some people's house over it was
Galena Street they had an apartment up
in tremendous we had a catch a fear
factor executive in New York we had to
catch her because she passed out on the
street stepped outside of a bar this is
after September 11th it was the the
coolest time to be in New York man
everybody was so goddamn friendly it was
like less than a year since the attacks
and were filming like maybe a year I
don't say it's 2002 somewhere and so
we're standing outside this this bar and
I go who wants some of this come on
pussies who wants some of this I pulled
out a joint and they got crazy they go
yeah we'll do it we'll do it with you
Mike oh my goodness you guys are fucked
like they don't have any idea like
non-smokers have no I mean they might
smoke we a little bit in college you
know what the fuck you're getting into
if no idea crazy sweet is oh my goodness
so she took one hand and she's standing
there and then just here eyes like
slowly start to roll back and I see her
body give in and we just rushed in and
Carter were like whoa
and then we call the ambulance yeah yeah
didn't know what was going on she had
had a few health issues too so we're a
little worried like something might be
going on other than the weed you know so
we called her call an ambulance for her
but it's weird watching someone blackout
from weed you know I told that story
about that one person in college that
she took one hit of a joint or a bong or
whatever it was she stood up and just
started running as fast as she could
into the bathroom and trips over the
bathtub and smashes her head into the
wall and she had no idea why I said she
said her body just took over and she
couldn't she didn't know what she
blacked out and she just started running
that should be the commercial we
[Laughter]
nothing's for everybody but anymore
nothing's for everybody including you
know fucking cats you know I know lady's
allergic to chickens she's like I love
chickens but I'm allergic to them what
the fuck are you talking about you're
allergic to
chickens are you how you allergic to
chickens how does that even happen can't
even pick up a chicken she I was a kid I
was allergic to dogs like a motherfucker
I mean really doctor I had to go to a
doctor if I had contact with a dog but
you're not like that now over the years
I just kept playing with them I couldn't
live like that I couldn't live like that
normal that's when she was a horrible
way to live if I went to somebody's
house as a child and they had a collie
or something it's khalili yeah collie
you know when you were kid and somebody
got a collie that's it
that's lassie motherfucker you know
that's as good as it gets and my
godmother had a collie my mom you can't
go now I got a fucking going out I see
him they call them lassie and I would
hug him in an hour later my eyes would
be like fluffed and I got punched in the
face both of them Wow and they make me
wash my hands after an hour they go to
the hospital they put some whatever and
I they tell me have to fuck with the
dogs I eight times I said dogs are my
fucking thorn in my side when I was a
kid from getting bit I got bit in the
face I got bit in the leg I got I kept
getting bit Oldman pinches kept biting
me German Shepherds are my bike kids
because kids have grabbed their face no
I never asked them I fear I had such a
fear of them and then one time I'm like
Spanish ha
a guy used to walk past me every day in
the summer and he had two dogs and he
would say don't tell a lot of my dogs
don't talk to my dog okay cuz I was
trying to work over the fear I knew that
somebody said you got to play with them
not they're gonna keep biting you and
bow after a summer one that and say a
lot of the dogs like the dogs are bought
by and the female came back and bit me
in the fucking leg so this is that time
like I haven't been scared of dogs at
all at all well there's some people that
have bad dogs though there's some people
that just have bad dogs they don't they
took didn't take care of the dog they
raised a shitty dog and the dogs
dangerous that's a fact listen man
thought was just you know you can't
every day we hear about a dog attack or
some shit you don't fuck well it's weird
we're living with animals we've got this
weird animal that we allow to live with
us and you know it protects you which
means what protects you means protection
from other people I mean one of the last
time you heard about a dog protecting
someone from an animal it's pretty rare
right they're protecting you from other
people and so you got a dog that's
trained to bite people which is very
strange animals that you have around you
that are essentially like trained
weapons trained to go after people like
when people have those attacks Shepherds
remember when George Foreman
when George Foreman fought Muhammad Ali
he brought his German Shepherd to Zaire
and it was this big deal because the
black people that lived there the at the
actual Africans that lived there fucking
hated German Shepherds because German
Shepherds are the dogs the cops a cop
said so they saw George Foreman as like
the enemy and muhammadi played on that
like a motherfucker he played on that
like a motherfucker and realized that
Georgia fucked up by bringing this
German Shepherd with him to Africa and
that's where the ollie boom bye-yay
ollie boom bye-yay a lot of that had to
do with Georgia well the only fight in
Africa just him
yeah in Philippines he fought Joe
Frazier races yeah Manila yep the
Thrilla in Manila that's the place where
he pointed the gun on them from the
bottom Joe's phrases on his balcony and
shit get in the Sun and Bob well he said
Joe Frazier and he pointed like I
started this pistol at him
did he really yeah it's crazy you know
Milo he was crazy in a funny way
I'm saying like he was crazy in a funny
way wolves I hear was you know that
video I showed you James Brown uh-huh
the first time I came in your pocket
that's where the video was taken because
it was George Foreman against Muhammad
Ali Don King said wait a sec I ain't
stealing enough on this fight I might as
well get a musical performance get a
bunch of motherfuckers out here steal
from them too and I just robbed a bunch
of black people all at once right right
so he robbed he got the spinners he got
he got James Brown he got all these
black bands to go to fucking Zaire and
perform as a music festival celeea
cruise he got the funny all-stars he got
a who well he got like just all these
black bands and what happened he
probably just stiffed me shit
he probably just stepped them to he's
like I didn't make enough money no gonna
cancel that fight what I think something
was wrong with that fight hook it up
something happened it was gonna get
pushed back oh really he had the music
already set up is very interesting that
that I they made a movie about it called
soul power
and that's who's the guy that says
lovely day lovely day Bill Withers
I don't remember yeah Bill Withers is in
that in that movie fucking tremendous
that was uh they made a documentary
about that fight to write when Kings
watch like pieces of I never watched the
whole thing good not bad you know as
much as you could watch those but
there's a great picture of Muhammad Ali
with Bill Withers you know the guy sings
all those great love songs you don't
know with us and he's got his shirt off
in Africa the fucking steak and eggs and
Muhammad Ali is just dropping now it's
talking you know about the fight and
Bill Withers his next to him and he
won't look up he's just eating this
fucking steak is so yummy for your tummy
he won't look up no shirt on bill with
his fucking tremendous that was one of
Don King's first fights was it really
yeah it's apparently one of his first
ventures according to Wikipedia as a
professional boxing promoter and he
managed to get Ali and Foreman to sign
separate contracts saying they would
fight for him if he could get a five
million dollar purse so and then he took
that and then he went to this other
company I'd go to an outside country for
the event because
have the money so i ears president ready
for this name Mobutu say say Seco asked
if the fight could be held in his
country and eager for the publicity for
such a high-profile event blah blah blah
blah blah and they put together a bunch
of different investment different
companies invested some Panamanian
investment company British company bunch
of different companies and they all
coughed up the cash and threw it through
it together
what a fucking fight that was - I was
surprised what a fucking fight that was
that was one of my Muhammad Ali's
greatest performances ever because
nobody thought he's gonna win nobody
nobody people don't understand what he
or just when he was 70 - oh brother 74
Wow people don't realize what a
motherfucker George Foreman was back
then he was a motherfucker you know you
hit hard and he was like a silent Ally
but you didn't do a lot of talking but
he was just thugged to the max he was so
dangerous when he fought Joe Frazier and
to picked him up with a punch he hit Joe
Frazier so Hardy went up into the air he
was just a different thing you know Joe
Frazier was no walk in the park either
fuck those are three dudes there's some
scary fucking heavyweights I think Joe
Frazier is a really scary guy with that
fucking left hook to his it hits you
like a fucking bomb yeah okay yeah it
was a come over hook yeah he was like
tremendo be good guys it's hard to do
that like to just come up like that BAM
he throws whole body it's whole body I
never seen just fucking that hooked it
he knocked Muhammad Ali down with oh
what a picture-perfect punch
he was just swinging into that thing
even if you knew it was coming
yeah even if you know once you saw I'm
ducking like that once you saw him
taking that little step that little
crotch whatever that's call he would do
that shell to that Philly shell where he
put like one hand up one hand down and
bobbing and weaving and coming in
whipping shots Joe Frazier was a
motherfucker bad wasn't we used to go to
Philly we used to drive past his gym I'm
away from the a plan a but he lived at
his gym before he died yeah any but
broke in the end look the amount of
money that these guys make for the time
look they're talking about five million
dollar purses for Ali informant for the
time you have five million dollars back
then that is a
a lot of goddamn money but guess what
you live like you got five million
dollars so you're a buying fucking
Cadillacs and paying for this and paying
for that meals here and jets there next
thing you know five million dollars
doesn't even make it to the 80s and you
know the brothers are showing up at the
door my long-lost cousin yeah listen man
we got adventure and this motherfucker
can't go wrong
Bob shot some white neighborhood first
year gonna make 30% of your investments
second years 60% of estimate and they
just hit you with some crazy speech how
many of those you ever had to deal with
three oh you get them all the time I had
to deal with one recently movies TV
shows you get them consoles your
beatings man I'm not a movie producer
all you have to do is give us a check
and we'll do the rest you don't have to
do anything
you'd have to worry about yes I do I
have to worry about it no no no you
don't have to worry about it no no I do
have to worry about if I give you money
I'm gonna worry about it
get out of here you crazy idea does the
reason why they have banks okay go to
the bank if you have a really good idea
and you have credit go to the fucking
back if you don't have credit I gotta
assume somewhere along the line you've
already made some poor looking choices I
don't want to be involved in that people
have this everybody has this idea that
they they're gonna figure out how to
circumvent this time art system of
Hollywood they were gonna get to Joe
Diaz if I can get to chhoti as I know
Joe Diaz been counted on the road if he
can give me just $2,000 and I could
start this film you know Quentin
Tarantino this is my my ramaa Kevin
Smith made clerks and and they just
think that all they need is a couple
grand from Joey Diaz Joey Joey Joey Joey
you can't go wrong okay nobody makes
movies like me
okay Joey they just don't want me in
they don't want me and Joey
dick don't want me and Joey Diaz they
want to keep me on the outside so you
get them for your time it's not even
that you get them for money it's you get
them for your time yeah look at you
you're living through you you're busy
yeah you swamp there's no more no
someone I keep telling people that to
get mad at me no yeah they don't
understand when you have children
there's no schedule I can't count on my
schedule bro ten twenty she wouldn't get
off my fucking lap watching one two
three videos on YouTube at 10:30 yeah
she went to pick her up
go away what yeah what will you fuckin
talking about I'll be back in a couple
hours
you don't have no fucking idea what it
is to and I went to get to go into the
room at 9:30 to get out of it I was
gonna get out of the early got a little
bitch open the gate I I heard those
stomping and like there's there's no
argument she just puts hands put youtube
on I gotta sit there with a one two
three four or five you know and then she
again daddy okay
well the problem people ask you to do
things too is that you gotta do this
shit for yourself okay the way to do it
is not to go through other people and
ask people to pick you up and help you
that's not how it works it doesn't work
that way
okay everybody thinks they're gonna
figure out some fucking joke shortcut
because they know you or they know this
guy or that guy this there's no
shortcuts in creating something just
figure it out bitch I love stand up
because there's one part of me doesn't
need anybody I'll even open
mmm right here this is my tools for
stand up and a person
we're gonna go to Bob's fucking coffee
house on North Hollywood and do three
minutes you know me I don't give a fuck
yeah when we talked about having a band
that somebody came on here and said that
it was the toughest thing in the world
for a band to stay together you got four
people personalities you know you get
these people that come to you now and I
was breaking it down for you on the
plane it'll say hey Joe how you doing
my name is this read my script do you
like it yeah we're gonna get eight
million dollars and then you go okay
when you get it call me I really like
this script something you're interested
in whatever three days whole thing you
do get a call and they say hey we're
making a movie but guess what we didn't
get two million dollars we got two
hundred thousand dollars so instead of
you getting ten thousand a week you're
gonna get a hundred a day and it's gonna
be a hit we're gonna make it happen
not another ten they run out of money
for marketing mmm and editing and the
whole fucking things to your movie ends
up in YouTube they don't have a legit
schedule so you have to work Saturdays
and fucking Sundays you know those
people that are involved in those low
rent movies they're a fucking nightmare
and it's their dream and I get it's your
dream but don't include me in this
fucking thing because you want me to do
everything cheap on my end all the hours
and it's your fucking dream if it's
that much you're dreaming do me a favor
if we get the 200 G's go get another 300
G's and make this fucking work well not
only that you can find other actors out
there that will do it for cheap there's
people out there that just want to act
sort of like a comic will go to an open
mic night there's certain actors to just
want to do something to put it on a real
go find them there's a lot of talented
people out there that are not working as
far as like acting goes there's a lot of
fucking people that can do it
there's a lot of lovely people it's just
the I just have a problem people like
asking you to help them do it like I get
it from comics all the time to just
looking for a break what are you talking
about you see you're not you're not
gonna get a break from another comic the
way you get breaks is by going onstage
and being funny like go to an open mic
night be funny the club will say hey
Joey Diaz you're fucking funny we would
like you to come here more often the
audience really enjoyed you next thing
you know some manager says you know what
Joey Diaz you're really funny we would
like to think about taking you on as a
client and that's how it works like a
comic coming along is not gonna make you
funnier and then the people that do that
they always have a distorted perception
of how good they are already you know
those those kids that are asking for a
break the kids that want you to help
them hey Madge need a break if I could
do sf4 you really help my like and
that's not you don't you don't go the
Doug Stanhope show and ask for a fucking
guess all our Doug will probably put you
up dr. Potter all right 2:15 start go up
front
Doug will push a parking open Micah and
his first time onstage he'll do that in
front of like a crowd in Norway or
something but that stand-up you know
it's not normal yeah you have to do it's
amazing what people you know we weren't
like that thank God
we knew that this took work and hard we
knew that this to what wasn't gonna
happen in one night I was old enough
already when I started I was longing the
truth already that I knew this was just
not gonna you know you just didn't walk
onstage and things happen and people
come here and they call Desperados where
they just do don't come up to you for a
guest then you're gonna ask him what is
this gonna do for you Ryan how's this
gonna fucking change the way it's like
I've never been to much of a hangout I
don't believe in that I never believe in
that shit you know I believe in doing
this spot if I go to the economy shows
I'm doing a fucking spot final goal I
don't go to the improv my name isn't on
that list the Hangout
there's no for me there's no no
no no because if you come up to Joe
Rogan Redman or Jamie and go hi Jamie
my name is Joey Diaz I'm a fucking count
I'm a funny comic Jamie's gonna say are
you going up tonight because we all want
to watch it I love to laugh but you're
funny let's go no I'm just here hanging
out yeah that's fucking funny if you're
not on the list that's not funny or they
don't know about you yet there's a
possibility though no no people that go
to the improv
that's it they'll tell you dog you got a
network what network network on stage
I've networked on stage yeah when they
laugh and I walk off
that's network well not only that when
you're a comic you're sort of like a
fruit or a vegetable in that you're
you're growing and then you get a one
day you're gonna be ripe and when you're
gonna be ripe everyone's gonna know
about it people find out about you
people people found out about everybody
they found out about you they found out
about Hinchcliffe I know about everybody
hear about Duncan you know what happened
what's happening in China right now
what's happening in China
oh yeah every night he goes I can't
believe there's white people and UFC
fans yeah okay they're not big rooms
they're 120 seasons II this it's like
coffee shops right but we're on the
Internet
the city worldwide this is worldwide
yeah this is you can't believe it that
there's fuckin people walking around
here going we came to see you from Macau
I can't believe it took people so long
to figure it out Ari's a fucking genius
he's a great comic it's uh it's just
amazing that people have misled they
think they shortcut you we got here what
was the shortcut if you get out of the
Tonight Show right that's it how many
people have gone in The Tonight Show and
now great success no one cares a lot of
people now it doesn't know but back in
the day I meant something big you know
Stephen Wright days use it on Letterman
that's it and you're Roseanne Barr yep
well you had on the show recently you
know who's a perfect example of a guy
who paid his dues who's just out there
silently murdering Ian motherfucking
Edwards Ian's motherfuckers killing
people don't know Ian Edwards is one of
the fastest comics in the country for
one of the very best like not not like
top 30
he's like top 20 maybe even top 15 he's
a murderer dude he killed me the other
night at the improv
he's very subtle subtle and Suffolk her
jokes are perfect the perfect structure
it's like he's got a perfect inflection
something he's so slick in Hawaii like
loose and relaxed like where is he going
with this blast me go crazy he's the
killer do not he's so I'd like his voice
because he's his boy skills yeah that's
what I like about that's the his
strength is house he's got a new sea
beast
yeah it's on DVD it's on the Conan
O'Brien's record label it's the first
one it's called a hundred percent
half-assed it's a really funny man he's
fucking really good right now
I've known Ian since the 90s dude I knew
Ian in the early I think I knew him in
1990 so think about that before you yeah
I've known that dude for 20 least 23 I
know I knew him when I lived in New York
and that was like I think I moved in New
York in 91 so I knew him from then on
this week great guy always been a great
guy I've always been a great guy like
can't can't say enough good shit about
that dude and he's a vegan I don't even
give a fuck yes yeah very very least a
vegetarian dudes awesome so I got a shit
in a cup on Friday three of these what a
segue by the way I've done that shit the
cup yeah three different little kind of
test tubes you have to put pieces of
poop in three different ones what what
are they testing it for cuz they tested
me for tapeworm scum from bad sushi know
everything I'm going in for the 50 and
then the fourth I got a drink a potion
for a day and vegetable water water
water water than Monday at 6:00 a.m. I
go to Wilshire to see the sunlight they
give me anesthesiologist they put a
camera at my asshole
they make sure there's nothing in there
they pull it out and then you have to
have so you have to fart once once you
fart you're good to go let's go have you
ever had a dog that had worms yes yeah
you're seeing it in their poop yes the
white things no here's a thing ever man
I had a dog she had she had worms and
when she'd poop you would like see it
cut out of her ass like it would on the
edge of her little
booty hole they'd be like little worms
like twisting and tweaking around and
they fall off it was disgusting
she had to get some anti worm medication
and kill everything that was inside of
her
yeah I thought my current dog had it
because every time she shits she wipes
her ass after she shits he just like
rubs her butt on the grass yeah exhaust
and I'm like oh that's me and she has
worms but now she's sometimes it's just
itchy but yeah doesn't seem doesn't your
butt itch sometimes once the dog figures
out they could rub their ass in the
carpet that's got to be pretty goddamn
dynamic they get those toes up in the
air you know that move like they're like
doing yoga and then they just start
fucking scooting that butt along with
the little toes ease up
does your dog a cat just non-stop puke
all the time my cat has taken to this
new habit of shitting in weird rooms in
the house yeah it's disgusting oh yeah
she's 18 years old she's really she's
not
they got dementia - she doesn't know
what's going on she's dimension miles in
the middle of the night in the middle of
mission doesn't know where she is just
oh man when you come out you always
think she's dying like why she's like
now okay fuckhead
don't be waking me up waking me up like
you're screaming in y'all we catch is
very needy man very needy I think I want
to get some work done and sit down in my
office sometimes I have to put her out
in the hallway she'll just keep hopping
in my lap I'm like listen bitch I got to
work but she looks at you like is your
free massages no did she doesn't like
anybody else in my house either because
she doesn't like my little kids you know
and she remembers my stepdaughter is a
little kid too so like she's no little
kids like she's like get the fuck out
everybody out out everybody out she
doesn't want to have nothing to do with
kids so like she just runs away from
everyone in the house but me so when I'm
not home the bitches hides she's high
it's just like where is this bitch like
if I'm on the road for like five days
she's like what the fuck is going on
here where is this asshole so as soon as
I come home it's follow me around so I
better since she was a baby she was a
little tiny kid I got for my sister my
sister had a cat and the cat got fucked
by some wild cat they lived in the
outside of Boston like suburbs like you
call the suburbs but it's pretty
like they had coyotes and shit and they
had raccoons would tear apart their
trash and they had wild cats a lot of
wild cats like feral cats were pretty
common but there were people's pets you
know they were wild but they weren't you
know they weren't like dangerous wild
cats like farm cats they were just
people let their cats out the cats would
go run around fucking so it was
old-school
cat gave birth in the middle of the
kitchen they put it in a box shit out
some kittens and she had all these
kittens I took one of them and that spaz
she is 18 years later she's like she's
fine
like I think mrs. Rogan probably wanted
her dead a while ago shitting in various
spots of the house but I can't go on
nowhere - sure my cat I guess she just
came in she stayed in the car but yeah
she was alive and it seemed like she was
good enough to get in a car and stuff
yeah I didn't say about my friend
Johnston for young comics playing she's
just just if you find out that she's
gonna be there just go there to stare at
her yeah go there to stare at one of the
most important figures in the history
comedy draw her just go look at her just
so you could say I saw Mitzi Mitzi shore
in real life he should do that because
she ain't gonna be here forever that
lady's one of the most important figures
ever in comedy if it wasn't for her I
would have never without a doubt and
never been the same comedian I wouldn't
be at this table I would have been gone
I would never been the same she that
that lady she threw me into the fire
trial by fire every time there's anybody
anybody good at the Comedy Store
Martin Lawrence when he's in his prime
doing movies guess who's going after
Martin Lawrence right here kid don't up
there to eat a fat plated dicks and
learn how to do stand-up put me behind
Paul Mooney for a year at midnight to
really torment my lab I see a lot of
Dahmer and AJ Jamal I give you all three
is fuckin problem but destroying my
fucking and breaking me down every night
that's how I got back up by doing blow
I would leave there depressed and have
to do fucking rock just to get back home
all right I got another hope I got
tomorrow night and
whoo my father was a even if it wasn't a
J whoever was in front of a J would
cancel and AJ would be it was a fucking
nightmare guys it was a mall was sooo
squeaky clean squeaky god damn hilarious
hilarious beautiful timing it was hard
to go on after always like driving
through Jitsu you're gonna die why am I
even doing this shit why the fuck am i
going I'm just going to be on bottom and
stuff all fucking day
by the way I gotta ask you a question
with your animals I know you don't watch
it but you gotta watch this shit there's
a lot of affect you I watched that real
sports with buffa Bruce Buffer yeah see
the story before that you know horses
know how they juice it if you think
Vandelay in jail with juice little
fucking nines what they do you know many
horses died an aqueduct race trail loan
in January this Jesus from steroids 26
well that's what all those like
equipoise remember equipoise
bodybuilders would take that is a horse
tear equi is like whore equine it's
about horse I'm asleep but doing this
you're right steroid my brother look it
up there beyond aquatics aquatics they
give them decade' Roblin for germans
they give really yeah well 26 horses in
one month for weeks divided by 26 that's
a lot and then that I'm watching this
and I had to go to the track I had to go
to Santa Anita that Saturday for a kid's
thing they paint your face in the middle
and write the kids on horses I was
looking forward from me you know what I
ain't going I told my wife that my own
boycott that shit I said it she was Joey
you gotta go you already make commits
mr. kids I went up there third race
fucking horse died the heart attack to
fall down they just bro they're just
dead dying on the track again ha they've
just juicing them to the gills for the
gills bro speaking of juice to the gills
pull up that video that I put on my
Twitter page yesterday about the
strongman guy breaking his back see that
he didn't break his back apparently he's
okay what apparently is okay his body
failed in the middle of lifting what
they call an atlas stone and Atlas stone
is like a globe like a giant globe
but it's a rock and that weighs like 300
plus pounds and this guy's hoisting this
rock up on to these pedestals and he's
in the middle of Helena's rock up on the
pedestal and I guess he blacked out from
the strain I guess he was straining so
hard that was like he was getting choked
because like he didn't have any oxygen
his brains just boom he falls down in
this fucking huge boulder lands on look
at this dude check this out look at the
size of this fucking boulders voicing it
up he's trying to get it up there
[Applause]
call fucking 9-1-1 right now
why is that funny why you laugh because
III won't watch the video but I was
watching the guys okay the guys okay
everybody thought that he broke his back
and that was the the title of the video
but apparently what happened was he just
blacked out and really had nothing but
cuts and bruises um even went on to
finish the event which is crazy
you know I don't know how the fuck the
guy did it three hundred plus whatever
the fuck it is pound huge thing landed
on his body I don't know how the hell
you survived that I'll ask you some
steroid questions sure is deca still
relevant do people still do all these
steroids I talk about from the 80s like
anavar and withdrawals this I'm sure if
you're in bodybuilder circles you know
it's not for MMA fighters and what mfa
MMA fighters get popped for more than
anything it's testosterone just because
you can get regular testosterone now so
easy there's so many people that are
getting testosterone replacement therapy
prescriptions they like it's gonna like
100 or something set in the last three
years more I probably more probably more
chiropractors yeah fucking making a
killing tire practice they're the ones
who do it the most they what prescribe
to what they do is what they do is they
get a doctor in house uh-huh you get
some slub like the medical marijuana
doctors retires wife it's a lottery yeah
you ever go to a medical marijuana
doctor they're all over 60 I won't for
the great one a banana peel they don't
give a fuck they've already been sued
any times when I give a fuck you're not
gonna get sued for this shit like that
one guy that gives us the weed
prescriptions that has he's the best
he's the best he's the one that shows up
with you and fights the court and tells
us not only that he went to jail yeah he
went to jail lost his practicing with
the jail in the 90s he was one of the
first adopters but uh yeah you know what
we talkin Oh the chiropractor
I brought it I didn't smoke but I didn't
either half a cookie yeah I hear him
don't get me wrong I did have nothing
wrong I'm a fan so uh they what you do
is you partner up with a doctor
you put her in the office uh-huh you go
upstairs you draw blood you come
downstairs a week let your no one
testosterone
yeah you need a real doctor to do that
because you need to get all your if
you're gonna fuck around like that you
got to get all your your levels measured
your thyroid level measured your idea
they I mean they're real doctors Joan
but I didn't know what they're doing
yeah they send you to they do all the
paperwork and you go upstairs with the
test and then they read it to you they
prescribed the blockers they grab
everything all at once it's just you're
working you're working very closely with
the chiropractor and the chiropractor is
not some guy who walks around with
sandals right this guy is six foot six
292 pounds fucking 90% yeah if I show
you this chiropractor here we go oh yeah
oh yeah that's the man motherfucker you
know chiropractors it's a very
controversial science if you want to
call it a science practice you know some
people believe in wholeheartedly some
people think it's total horseshit have
you sat with them for a while no
solitude I got a good card I have a good
I have a good friend to count but he has
a bunch of things in his office that I
also like he has like a really good
massage therapist
he works on stretching with people but
it was like he's big on posture like a
lot of things that I know about posture
come from him like he explains it and
like some no bullshit
terms and he he also explains like like
your whole like when people stand this
is what's wrong with slumping I always
thought slumping just looks sloppy he
goes no it's putting undue pressure on
certain areas their spine your spine
when you sit up straight and you stand
up straight your spine supports itself
in a straight line but anytime you move
head forward you're putting all this
pressure like an uneven point like in
the middle of your back you're but
essentially we're supposed to be like
dogs
we're supposed to be walking on all
fours you know there's a reason why
chimps most chimps walk on all fours
it's like they don't have back aches
it's like it's a better way of moving
when human beings start standing up
apparently the flaws in the design of
the back
began to surface like we're not done yet
like what eventually the body as it
stands like now with this back issues
that most people have from picking
things up
most likely the body's gonna evolve over
the course of the next million years or
so and do probably a much stronger
version of a back in the future
now the kettlebell training has helped
your back oh yeah for sure it says it
basically says about people's backs um
when you start kettlebell training your
back becomes they use this word
resilient yeah well you get muscle all
the the whole look if you feel someone's
back if you go and like feel the actual
back muscles themselves if you have more
stronger back and also supporting your
spine it just makes sense if you
practice proper posture and you have
more muscle and stronger muscles
supporting the core of your body then
you can resist movement unexpected
movement like say like in jiu-jitsu
class or something like that if like you
get yanked to the side back and forth
the stronger your core is the more
you're protected from that you know like
like if you roll the guy's got a really
strong core like judo guys specifically
you can't move those fuckers around man
their core is so goddamn strong so if
you're trying to like lean against their
core compress their core it's like
either flip them over or sweep them
their core is so goddamn strong it's
like they're pillar the what connects
their body together is just you can't
get through that fucking thing wrestlers
same thing especially greco-roman guys
their upper body and their core so
fucking strong from throwing bodies
around all the time and that's sort of
what kettlebells mimic just throwing
things picking things all wasting things
with momentum are all that stuff that
all builds core they're all builds when
everybody likes to call core but people
do sit-ups and leg lifts and shit get
the fuck out here with that you don't
need that you need heavy kettlebell
swing those motherfuckers and press them
and do windmills that's where you get
strong my weight loads wait do I
increase the way to avoid creeps the
reps work increase the work okay the
more we fight you listen you can do 45
pounds for an hour or you can do 55
pounds for 40 minutes what that's all in
how much you put in versus how much you
get out as far as for health benefits
when you go heavy the problem is your
risk injuries when you go like 55 pounds
70 pounds 90 pounds once you get that
gets a little squirrely because you're
hoisting a lot of goddamn weight and
you're carrying it in all these fibers
and tissues you straining when you're
doing like 55 pounds or 45 pounds it's
not that much weight so you can get in a
lot of reps and you get it exhausted
like that that's what I do get to the
point where at the end my form sucks
once my form starts to stop I step back
yeah that's that 14 and like I do I try
to do 10 sets of swings infinitively you
know times 12 sometimes I'll do nine and
I rest a minute I'm on a minute timer
then I do another 1416
then I rest a minute another 12 15 I go
with my body right once I get done at
once I do 10 of those 45s I I do the
single ones mm-hmm and I do 15 of those
like seven to one and I switch it to
eight in the other and vice versa Christ
still with a minute by the time I get to
the 14th one I can feel my form starting
to fade that's when it's over pick up
the 235 and I walk around the block like
I can't take it no more for my workout
that's my posture that's it that's all
rate workout listen I've read I've read
extensively I hang out with you I have a
friend who has a coach and he goes the
thing about kettlebells is though forgot
that 50 the less is the better but go
with your body know what it tells you so
they started a program at this place now
five days a week cattle bells 20 minutes
a day you guarantee 10 pounds in one
month to lose a certain diet and then
bonus really I just haven't been able to
grab it on the road Thursday Friday
Saturday but I'm home the next three
weeks and I'm gonna work on it I'm gonna
go in there you can either go at night
or in the morning 20 minutes it's just
it's great work you know it's great work
for your body when you would you do it
it combines all the benefits you get
from lifting weights with all the
benefits that you get from doing cardio
you can get it all together in one
movement it's just you force your body
to do shit and if you do you know the
workout that you're talking about right
there that's a good work good work it's
a very good workout and then I like how
you're ending with the farmers walks I
open up with the farmers walk that's a
good way to one is with the farmers walk
instead of I walk I get
I pull them down I rest a minute pick
them up and just walked as much as I can
sometimes I make it to Burbank Boulevard
oh yeah why not it's 10 o'clock at night
I'm not doing nothing why not if
somebody you know mug you by bang and I
like doing them bro in the mornings I
park my car in front of my house go on
my truck I got the kettlebells in my
trunk got to boxing gloves I got shin
guards
I got a yoga mats awesome because
sometimes I'll go to fucking North
Hollywood Park mm-hmm that's why I think
I got I killed my meniscus or was that
North Hollywood because I walk that
thing and then do the kettlebells and
they got that one hot corner over there
that's always 150 degrees I don't know
what it is about Hollywood Park that
it's beautiful the walk is beautiful but
there's a dip where the Sun even at
night that shines even at night the Sun
shines there in that corner well yeah I
carry I liked it I like to do the
kettlebells outside yeah and I do them
inside I get anxiety I get hot I can't
breathe I do them outside under the Sun
I blasted my way from 9:15 the 10
o'clock
my body's burning shit all day you know
what I just got from my kettlebell what
a bowling ball carry-on bag for an
airplane because you can carry 50 pounds
you take 50 pounds with you and check it
so that check this fucking cannonball I
throw it in there the TSA is gonna shit
their pants they try to pick up this
little bag it's that big it weighs 50
pounds
it's a great fucking idea yeah check it
you just check it they get mad at you
but whatever our 35 55 yeah 35 is good
look that Keith Weber kettlebell cardio
workout that they sell it on 35 pounds
you do it it's a tremendous workout I
just you just keep going he just keeps
going just over and over again all in
the beginning first couple minutes it's
kind of easy but then you get 5 minutes
and 6 minutes and you're like oh shit
you realize you got to do this for 40
fucking minutes holy shit things you
think would be easier clean press with
35 pounds it's nothing right and not
when you're exhausted when you're
exhausted when you keep going your legs
are on fire the next day barely be able
to touch your toes
so you can travel with one of those
throw that video on and have a great
workout but for
most people what the most important
thing is just building up slow don't try
to get it all like I haven't worked out
in five years so today I'm fucking
running the mountain I'm gonna do click
no no go light do a little bit of work
today but be consistent that's the key
be consistent like a little bit of work
one day relax rest a little bit more
work out the next day relax rest chart
your progress and then what you said
listen to your body look I could finally
do a technical get up a Turkish get up
no I technical get up in jujitsu I can
finally do it after a year practice in
hotel rooms five a day I would doing my
right side and I'm a nut dog right you
do know I'm retarded half what people
know that I'm a little stupid
I'm geeky you know I don't like I don't
like being bad at something and since we
got the comedy work that ethic I know
that you could turn anything in life
into something if you just keep showing
up yeah if you just you know like for me
to Jitsu has been I suck Joe but I can
finally do the whole gym hip escape that
fucking I'm a black belt in HIPAA
escapes to me today that's what I do I'm
a hip escape expert that's what I work
on you know this games a huge bro fuck
and when you learn how to doing for you
know what I was doing and it salami
taught me sometimes all just taught me
in different and I put it all together
on my shoulder and now at least I could
pick up my ass and push it all the way
back for me those are little things you
know I wish I was better but I know if I
keep going to jujitsu twice a week which
is what my body can handle eventually
I'll get something on bar eventually
because I got funny with comedy I was no
fucking to slip Magoo in the beginning I
just kept showing up go you just gotta
keep showing the fuck up
that's half a life that's half a life
and what gives a fuck how I'm not
looking for a black belt I'm not even
looking beat nobody up I'm just looking
to go to learn Turkish get up I could do
with 10 pounds the Turkish get up I'm up
to this point where I put my arm down I
put my knee up and I just go up to my
elbow and I go down I do ten of those
bro but I don't even go out with I've
been doing a fake months kettlebells
10 pounds turkeys get a bitch but I'm
still doing it right what would happen
if I woulda took 35
you know me dog I get that I wouldn't be
here right now my shoulders being my
fucking halo so but at least I know this
going in because because of the lesson I
got from comedy that it don't matter
though just keeps you yep dog keep
showing some people you chumps stay on
some days you don't want man
for some people it's like me when we did
comedy there was eight people who had a
chance there was another six who were
funny but they had day jobs because they
were married who I had children
then you had two people who do it as a
hobby that every once in a great while
they drove to a gig and then you got
three people that just had mental health
issues yeah okay so she showed up every
week and they were nice enough but she
knew there was something wrong there and
for them it was the way this is for me
with jujitsu I'm not looking for them me
they're not looking to be on NBC all
they want to do is one time in their
life make somebody laugh how special is
that
that's huge and they go down and you
miss those guys I miss those guys when
my scenes in Seattle even here and then
lay there's people that you see them and
they're a pleasure to talk to because
they don't want an agent they don't want
to be on movies they're just having fun
they work at Universal City in the
daytime as the hope very there's very
few of those most of those guys have
dreams that just never manifested
themselves but a lot of them never
material I meant a lot of guys that bro
they were proud of their job they just
thought somewhere in their life that
they could be a stand-up and they just
didn't want to die without trying it
right and then they did it and become
addicted how many people go to jiu-jitsu
it becomes addicting yeah stand-up
definitely becomes Dick's and it becomes
it becomes addicting and it's like
addicts where you see those guys are
scrambling outside they can't wait to
get on stage and like even guys are bad
they'll see a guy who's up there killing
like you be able to stay on like man
he's supposed to only be doing 15
minutes motherfuckers or 20 minutes like
what do you care what are you gonna do
you're gonna go up after Joey Diaz what
are you gonna do you're an open mic ER
and you're upset like they think somehow
another thing I'm on the non-paid
regulus but you're not getting up until
2:00 in the morning
you know how it works this is what you
do you're a novice a non-paid regular
you get up after everybody else that's
what you do if there's anybody fuckin
crazy as that people should know this
you wanna you were on a TV show and you
were not a regular which by law if
you're on a TV show you're allowed to go
in there bump bitches
even the Bell yeah I'm saying well not
only that I showed up every night every
night I was there I think this lesson I
learned about this whole thing from you
it was news radio on Fridays you got
there 11:00 in the morning wardrobe
stupidity laughter food and then they
either clock your shoot you'd be
strolling in there at fucking 11:30 bro
I respect you for that to this day that
meant more to me and you didn't need it
$15 it's not like you had 19 kids you
need the 15 fuckin dollars I'll tell you
the truth being passed as a paid regular
at The Comedy Store meant more to me
getting on TV shit me too
when I was on a TV show when I was on
news radio one of the things I loved
about you come to visit me I was like
finally there's another motherfucker
that doesn't belong here because I was I
was always wandering around like one day
they're gonna tell me to get the fuck
off TV but until now somehow or another
I'm on TV so Joey would show up I black
come here man hey come on let me show
you what this is just where they keep
the food wander around the set Joey
would show up at the set and Joey would
be sitting they had an executive VIP
suite and the VIP suite they had shrimp
cocktails and delicious hors d'oeuvres
and they had it catered a dude who you
know had like one of those Mumford &
Sons fucking facial hair things with a
beautiful tie a thin skinny time he'd be
like serving people shit and it would be
all these NBC executives and Joey
fucking Diaz with a leather jacket would
stroll in and feast he'd be sitting
there with a fucking paper plate with
like 15 shrimps on it oh my god is that
your friend can I ask you something has
ever been a week that you caught
yourself after a couple of days and
you've gone fuck why I'm in such a bad
mood people definitely I do it all the
time guys like I fucking go
frantic like for two nights I go I'm
gonna stay in right I'm gonna be George
Carlin it needs to go out by fucking
Thursday I'm salivating by Thursday
I wake up with that fucker and also I'm
on the flappers website I'm on the
Icehouse website I'm looking for a spot
you know right I don't call it no way
I'm just looking you know well it's a
fucking it's definitely an addiction
absolutely that's a positive addition
yes definitely and the more addicted you
like right now I'm super addicted sure
you got big things going on but I was
longest yeah I got my my special that
I'm gonna fit record in August with
tickets still haven't been on sale for
yeah but it's gonna be at the Comedy
Works in Denver and I'm doing it in the
little Club to downtown Club oh that's
ferocious it's like a den of thing for
this I can't fuck but you're back to day
one but you have this family you're
writing again you're looking at little
words now and that gets you fired up all
over again that really does well I'm
just right now but I've never been more
excited about stand-up didn't right now
I'm so I'm so into it but all the other
things that I do I love working for the
UFC I love it I love doing podcast but
stand-up right now is my motherfucker
just I'm just enjoying it so much I'm
joined joined watching it I'm enjoying
doing it I'm enjoying writing it I'm
excited about it it's fun it's a fun
time you know and the Icehouse man the
ice house has helped me a lot having
that place where we we perform there on
a regular basis having such a cool staff
and everybody's 9:00 Bob the owner just
being such a good guy it's get such a
good vibe in these shows that we've been
and we've got a show there tonight these
shows that we do they're they're so
fucking fun tonight's Ian Edwards Brian
Cowen Tony Hinchcliffe Sam Tripoli me
we're gonna murder that thing that place
is a special like like a magnet for fun
there's a lot of fun times
fuck yeah it's it's at times there it's
everything that the comic store used to
be but positive there's no negativity
there there's no darkness that like
hovers over the place it's not the same
but we're at different times in our life
and what was good about the Comedy Store
when I was 25 it's not good about the
Comedy Store now you know I don't I
don't want that nonsense in my life
anymore
but what's good about the ice house is
like all the good things like an old
comedy club with like a lot of history
but none of the pretentiousness none of
the bullshit not stuck on sunset so
dickwads come over from the sky bar all
that you know the the al
that you get in Hollywood that extra
dickwad fucking actor element you don't
get that in Pasadena
you know Pasadena is just all positive
let me tell you something man I I'm
doing the ice house next weekend with
Dom around you know and I just call them
this is the truth guys I we talking here
down the phone and I had the computer
open have something like well let me see
if he's got like the recent set to see
what he's doing you know Dahmer Aaron
yeah always writing and Doug I put the
set on from Rodney and I gotta be honest
here ideas don't on my eyes I'm so proud
of myself it was so like I remember
watching that fucking special and just
getting anxiety from going Jesus I'll
never be that fucking good like my god
not as a comic but even as a human being
like Here I am at a halfway house
watching this fucking tape of him and
Bill Hicks and Dyson God knows who else
is on that Lenny Clarke you know I love
Lily Clark in the beginning bro Lenny
car song and I'm like I'll never be this
good to be and Here I am next weekend
I'm at the fucking ice house with them
forever co-headline are you fucking
kidding me
I mean are you fucking serious that
means more than a movie because I
remember that dream couple weeks ago I'm
in Austin Texas at the bar having a
salad and who comes up and gives me a
hug Joe Torre listen man Joe Torre used
to have a routine on Def Jam where he
used to talk about yeah I got a brother
that's what I'm saved well motherfuckers
not me
I love kill the motherfucker I just
bought a gun I can't wait to use it
in fact I go to the ATM every night with
a tuxedo on this shit do you know how
many times I fucking watch that stupidly
that fucking BT all stars and Dahmer
errors i sat there for hours going what
a shame I don't know never be in that
not in this lifetime I have to come back
as a decent human being
you reborn as a decent human being fuck
you're a very decent human being oh not
at that time when I'd be watching that
should I go okay so maybe if I do this
for 20 years
might be a little funny but I'll never
be his Joe Torre and every time I seem
to try it on the same thing I'm gonna
get more fucking tuxedo look at a lady
I'm a midnight shit you know just very
weird the times what's going on right
now yeah you see people well it's
awesome it's awesome it's awesome to see
the culmination of years and years of
work for me it's beautiful because I got
to see you really early on I mean I got
to see you you don't me don't comment
like a couple years when I first met she
is it was a mess it was six years in
when I met you yeah but when you came to
the comedy store that's when you got
real serious right bitchy short touches
you mm-hmm you you started in you did
Denver and said yeah yeah those are the
two spots the other was where I lights
got turned on mmm in Denver I was just
going up it's like jujitsu now I just go
there fucking around if he lets me grab
his call I grab his collar if he takes
me down so beat if I get him down Wow
right oh my god well now what do I do
yeah right that's what comedy was for me
in Denver but then I started doing time
I started doing wait 24 minutes and then
this opportunity came up in Seattle so I
went to Seattle Seattle was where there
was an open mic it was 18 times I'd open
my cojones in Tuesdays there was another
open mic after that open mic and another
open mic after that open mic and Tuesday
there was another open mind and these
were all decent places in Denver I had
the camera you know I hadn't got in the
head with a microphone in general one
time cuz he was flicking bottle caps at
the comics he is dave Hester oh if I
still see Dave test-drove today he'll go
what's happening killer because I
fucking hit this guy in the head with
the microphone batteries whatever you
wear you know me dawg I told him he
flicked one fucking thing up here imma
break this microphone over your fucking
head what did he do with his buddy click
bang bang they gave me 25 bucks hurt if
again I had to get the fuck out and I
took my steak to go in Denver you had
you had no comedy on Mondays I had the
Australian bar and Boulder which does
not exist there anymore
on Tuesdays I had Wendy ten three
minutes you got twice a month three
minutes at the comedy worse
those days Wednesdays read club 52
Thursdays you had El Torito and uh you
know by John Oh way is up there by John
Elway's and Englewood Colorado where
although Cherry Hill it's all the way up
there El Torito as soon as you got off
to i-70 and on Friday and Saturday you
would open Mikey you had dick you how
many fucking places I haven't see at on
a Friday night you how many places you
had a little Wednesday night you had two
coma
you had Seattle you had Everett you had
Bellingham on Sundays what place had
more comics when I think Seattle Seattle
you know just the core I had was me
Brody Josh wolf
Aisha Taylor went through there you know
I know well they were in San Francisco
so I know a lot of those people who are
the festivals and at the the comedy
competition and then the Hank
you know Steve McGrew Todd Jordan had
some hitters too but the open mic scene
wasn't that strong it was very in
Denver's yeah dear Denver but there was
one guy his name was Andy Payton he was
a fucking dead head tremendous guy he's
a mayor of a town he ran for politics he
was a genius he went to all these bars
and he got a night at each bar
they paid him a little bit every night
you got a little bit 20 bucks ten bucks
30 bucks but at least you got to go on
stage and he paid and also sold
advertising and put on a newspaper
I think III I give a lot of credit to my
career - Andy - you and - Mitzi shore
but Andy painted believed in me the way
Dick Darley believed in you because he
didn't give a fuck that I was dirty but
that motherfucker threw me bra on
Sundays he goes I'll give you 50 bucks
you gotta follow a line dancing class
Colorado Jack Achy Breaky Heart bitch
and I'd be the first comic up after Achy
Breaky Heart you want to talk about hate
you want to talk about know laughter
being give me 50 bucks on Sunday and in
those days on Sundays at 7:00 he should
drop my daughter off as soon as I
slammed the door I just go into tears
and I'd get on the seventy and I'd smoke
a joint by the time I get to the gate
I'd be brain fuckin though and I go on
that stage just to die it was like a day
of dying it was like five hours of my
daughter that I took their abuse and
then I had
I would go to this bar and fucking our
vana you've never even been taught about
it up in our van oh you see the sign
that's where I wane Ludwig is from okay
Arvada and I'd have to do this fucking
country bar Sunday night and he paid
them was a genius bro he had two of
those weeks so he would call you girl
you got the whole week Monday and I'm
talking Monday through Sunday
4030 they weren't to our drives ever
just dumped bars in Denver way before
the stadium went up this is when that
shit was a shit hole down there really
and the Comedy Works told him you're not
allowed in here because you got all you
competition right so he said really I'm
gonna teach you motherfuckers a lesson
he spanked him for about a year and a
half but then he moved he went to like
one of those small towns and he became
the man became a mayor there now he's on
Facebook and I think I went back and
forth with him at one time I thanked
them and asked he says he still does
Konami once a month in this town he went
to like imagine the mayor's doing
stand-up in your town yeah that's me be
a mayor for a long time there's a term
limits on being a man no cuz the man
from North Bergen mayor Sacco has been
there fucking at least fucking ten years
to say is term limits on there you can't
there's no term limits on Supreme Court
justices right and no it was something
that people don't like it's different in
places in Ohio and Cincinnati the term
limit is two successive four-year terms
it's different in different places
apparently huh that's got to be a
thankless fucking job being the mayor of
a town trying to keep everybody in order
there's crime in this town mayor fuck
I'm gonna stop the crime and stop people
from stealing shit
doing the bad did it might Island Jersey
put cameras up around the city that set
my communism why fucking come from the
dog yeah it was on you in the city on
the street you know Camden you know
camera all that police officers anymore
Camden is so broke there's just rampant
crime police officers so you know if
they did they'd just put cameras up
everywhere everywhere it's um Robo Cop
shit there
they're like living in the future I got
a secret for you motherfuckers I knew
Camden was the real deal in 1978 I
couldn't believe what I saw
and what'd you say I saw anarchy I've
been brought in one time on the street
in a drug deal one time in my life cuz I
get dragged on the street and drug me I
was in Camden New Jersey they don't fuck
around in Camden bro Pennsauken can then
that's a complete different world I got
robbed for a pound the coat I pound the
weed I had to go answer to people that
gave me money investors I didn't go pay
these people back and sell weed I had to
do what I had to do I fucked up but they
robbed me man they sent me to fuck up
Camden is the poorest city in the
country and it has the highest rate of
murder in the country no shit they got
no cop on the street in animals and in
New Jersey we played them one year in
basketball and Dennis still I'll never
forget there's a coach in our high
school that's in a wheelchair he got
paralyzed Dennis still went up to him to
spit his fucking face dawg in high
school when you spit in the handicapped
dudes face Jesus you ain't fucking
around you want to hear a crazy crime
statistic Camden New Jersey has a crime
rate of 78 percent per 1000 residents so
for every 1000 residents 78% of them are
gonna experience crime 78%
that's like how much crime do you
experience in Burbank 0% did you get 78
he got robbed by Dracula this fucking
guy yeah he was probably really loud and
it's not I know
Camden I had never seen anything like
that I had a buddy a basketball player
buddy I was from the Pennsauken and I
went down to visit his family once that
left there of my fucking jaw dropped and
I knew not to go back down I read all
these Kansas statistics now and I'm like
no shit that place was the edge of hell
30 fucking years ago I can't imagine
what it is now yeah Matt Taibbi wrote an
article about it I'm tweeting it right
now he wrote an article about candy
saying it's called apocalypse New Jersey
a dispatch from America's most desperate
town no jobs no hope and surveillance
cameras everywhere the strange sad story
of Camden population it's a good
question
what if it's like 14 people you know
there's a lot of fucking people what
surrounds Camden brother take a look for
you uncle Joey whoo there's a lot of
shit around New Jersey it's it's near
Atlantic City right right right right
it's I thought it was near Philadelphia
- mm probably
yeah it's across the Delaware River from
Philly there's 77,000 people if you
don't want to get fucked up don't go to
Camden Jack don't buy weed don't do
nothing I got tricked
there used to be this gas station North
Bergen went from called Putnam when I
became after my mom died I had an inside
guy and I robbed him once a month like a
fake robbery you know saying we'd go hit
him in the head he go down we'd take a
thousand and all he wanted was an 8-ball
he was a little half on the retardo fake
robbery all tremendous I worked at
Putnam fuel everybody from that high
school worked at Putnam fuel and you
robbed him to death until they fired you
Ernie was always the shift manager Ernie
had kids you look a fucked up building I
love cocaine man me and my wife loved
his wife was like 400 pounds
she didn't work you know he had to bring
the home fucking home and Joy's that
type of shit he worked at a gas station
they lived a terrible apartment but they
were cocaine heads and I was 16 I had
worked in a nice time I need 8-ball I'd
already how can we do is how can we make
this happen
he's a fake robbed me all right so you
know how many times I fake robbed Ernie
about six times the fact there's a kid
in Florida that has a story that I
showed up his husband tonight with a
with a diagram because you had a robbing
the same way right you had to go around
the building was cameras in the front in
those days so you hadn't go around the
back
ring the bell when he come out he had
the tax I couldn't be the same guy all
the time that robbed them but you were
gonna be fine you weren't gonna get
arrested just take the walk with me
trust me and he always told now whenever
he goes to the Commish Coco coming home
with him with a diagram and we're gonna
rob a gas station like a football player
because it was brilliant
robbed Ernie once a fucking every six
weeks look I had the KY where you had to
hit him you got to kick him in the
stomach his shit and like smack him so
he would bleed and the cops he would say
Ernie
nobody gets robbed like this one what do
you want me to tell you they know I'm a
fucking idiot bro we would rob them once
every six weeks and finally event that I
didn't bring them the eight ball when
that I just did as a boy you got pissed
off at me that was it
being around shady people like that like
growing up around shady people gives you
such a a different flavor to life just
is an extra element when you look at the
time it's probably little dangerous when
you look back on and laugh
there's simply I wish to work at this
gas station I worked at a gas station
for a little while and there was this
old guy he should come in the gas
station this old dude who had like one
of those classic bald guys who's bald up
top with the hair on the side looked
like you know you see a guy like that
you think he's like a normal guy
probably know this guy used to drive
this souped-up Buick and he was a total
pervert and all he could do is talk
about pussy this old man talking about
pussy
like gray hair on the sides of his head
just talking about fingering chicks
fucking chill he was a madman but being
around that guy made me realize that
like I see a dude like an old dude who's
bald with the fucking hair on the side
and I say well there's probably a nice
gentleman like no old pervert driving a
hot rod Buick finger and chicks realize
you're around people like that you know
that there's something else like there's
possibilities there's there's a lot of
different kinds of people in life and
sometimes just cuz someone looks like
someone that you've sort of already met
before like oh yeah I know that type now
you know you have no idea look at Ted
Bundy that was how Ted Bundy got all
those girls he looked like a normal
handsome guy he didn't look like some
IDI gain fucking psychopath with you
know creepy little beady eyes weird
strange lamp
no he looked like a guy that you'd want
a date Mike Harmon played oh yeah that
was a girl he escaped from the jail and
fucking Aspen through a window for a
while I thought I was crazy talk because
I lived everywhere with Ted Bundy lived
Oh for a while I thought I was crazy I
lived in Snowmass Village
he killed the chick he kidnapped her
from the Willowbrook hotel whatever in
Snowmass Mellon
and then we lived in Seattle that's
where he did most of his damage that was
cially didn't didn't he do someone
Florida was at the end the dormitory
that was the end I think looking up or
something for a long time I'm like maybe
I'm fucking crazy dawg yeah I mean I
mean in and snowman I mean yeah he
escaped from the Aspen fucking jail Ted
Bundy that was uh that was a scary one
that guy used to he used to pick up
girls and take them for rides in his car
and they realized there was no doorknob
on their side they would go to reach for
like the door to open it there's no
doorknob he would remove yeah the
doorknobs removed on the side of his car
2002 film Ted Bundy if you look at him
he's a handsome guy normal looking dude
is he still alive
nah they launched them did he kill him
yeah he was in a they launched them and
uh they celebrated his death and all the
towns we killed people they had happy
hours that drinks the Bundy and shit
yeah January 24th 1989 they killed him
he was age 42 at the Florida State
Prison he represent himself he was an
attorney but no I think he was he was he
didn't take the pass to something he did
a lot of crazy shit man
fuck yeah he killed a lot of girls man
he revisited his secondary crime scenes
for hours at a time grooming and
performing sexual acts with the
decomposing corpses until future
vacation and destruction by wild animals
made further interaction impossible he
decapitated at least twelve of his
victims and kept some of the severed
heads in his apartment for a period of
time as mementos on a few occasions he
simply broke into dwellings at night and
bludgeoned his victims as they slept man
he was their first kidnap they first got
him in 1975 for aggravated kidnapping
and attempted criminal assault and then
he became a suspect and a progressively
longer list of unsolved homicides in
multiple states fuck call at Colorado
and Florida huh goddamn
Florida finally watched him correct yep
till the dormitory that's where you got
University of Florida right Gainesville
was in Gainesville or something like
that yeah there's some there's a lot of
those fucking guys out there man
what what turns a guy like Ted Bundy
into someone who would do that shit damn
have you seen his Mort picks morgue pics
yeah when he got executed yeah and it's
like there's a color one there's a
black-and-white one the problem Ward
picks is for the fuck knows
that's real yeah yeah I didn't look good
shaves and said to yeah top of his head
looks like a blob or something that's
what they do when they're cooking you
scary shit man it's just scary shit that
someone could be like that
you know well the fucker killed cats
when he was six yeah yeah killed dogs
shit tortured Michael Vick Thomas shit
he fucking yes no he's bludgeoning women
in their fucking sleep and rape and
corpses what the fuck happens to people
bro yeah that is the question that the
fuck happens to people what is it about
people the ass which can go off and then
BOOM
all the sudden your Dylan Klebold in
Colorado shooting up your school what is
it what what combination of chemicals
and behavior and life or combinations of
curve balls and shitty genetics and all
sorts of different things cause someone
to be that way his his Beatle was on
display in a museum recently and they
found in it they found a bunch of items
that were in it and one was a crowbar
garage garbage bags an icepick a
flashlight torn strips of sheeting a
knit ski mask handcuffs and a strange
mask made from pantyhose what the fuck
and in Florida as if living in Florida
wasn't bad enough the idea what that guy
running around
imagine if Ted Bundy was alive today
that big 90% of Nancy Gracie show Ted
Bundy in Florida Florida wild fucking
places you stand up to it was one of the
wildest spots I was thinking that the
other day like that that Hollywood
improv the improv in Fort Lauderdale
Hollywood Florida
that fucking improv was one of the
wildest clubs in the goddamn country as
Brian counts favorite place to perform
he's like they're off the chain
of their animals I was just in there
let's go wait would you do with what you
do with myself but you bring anybody
with you you don't know they were like
oh you have to pay like 800 hours for a
hotel for to bring a feature for the
casino cuz they put you in the casino
they don't give you a second hotel room
no get him make him give you a dog like
they have hotel room I fuck you know I
thought it wasn't a casino was gonna be
boring wasn't that bad it was pretty
good as a matter of fact I had a good
time yeah it's a fun great time I really
don't have a good time if you're living
around there that hard rock it's a
decent I said no yeah it was great it's
not like those places where they do they
used to do king of the cage at and back
in the band days did you ever go to the
one of those with me no Eddie Bravo and
I went to a bunch of them Eddie used to
work for the Connecticut she was the
post the commentator so we would travel
sometimes to these these gigs were in
the middle of fucking I mean nowhere
these weird Native American casinos were
the only places where he could do it
because they had sovereignty over their
own land so even though MMA was banned
in California at the time they could
still put on fights at these casinos
that's when people started to wake up
because it's like we'll probably make it
this a week you have much fucking money
these people are making because you
would go to the middle of nowhere
I mean hours and hours drive and there
would be thousands of people there for
an event all people we knew you know
people we knew from jujitsu guys we
trained with guys we knew that we're
like tap the tap out guys in the early
days and we'll go there and they'd have
these outdoor arenas like this outdoor
like seeded stayed most the time no
cover over it if it rained the fights
kept going they made a whole DVD called
wet and wild where they let it rain it
was fucking pouring out and in the
middle of these crazy torrential
downpours dudes were fighting it's the
dumbest idea of all thought well
couldn't but you had no traction at all
you would throw up on she would fucking
go flying because they had one of those
old school vinyl floors if it was a
canvas floor it would still be slippery
but it would be less slippery but this
shit wasn't canvas this shit was like
like vinyl so it was like a swimming
pools like slip and slide it really was
like trying to have a kickboxing match
on slip and slide
dude
knees get blown out fall on top of each
other like it was like one of the
sloppiest MMA cards ever but kind of fun
because it's a piece of history I don't
think they should ever do it again
but it's good that it exists but I think
this probably probably pull down from
YouTube we put a video on her but it's
funny if you ever got a boulder again
though make sure though the rope is no
robot into what is that's a cool mother
what is this that place it's a Buddhist
College really I went out of Monday I
used to go to when I was fucked up in
the head right I thought I didn't know
what I want to do with my life I was
confused after prisoner knowing I would
go down Mondays and walk meditate I
learned how to meditate there I went to
a seminar I seen Allen Ginsberg there
and you know it's all vegetarians fucked
I went to a massage therapist and I was
tremendous you know one time I able to
love myself she stunk so bad but the
massages were so good like a smile her
fucking armpits and the humus on there
was fucking hard but they were the
nicest fucking people in the world and
they always have a course that you'll
look at and go huh what class they're
teaching it like you know what man I was
young right before commie I was
frustrated I was married I didn't know I
would go there I've ever taken like a
humanitarian course you know but it was
so I think now would be more interesting
to me because now I've gained more
knowledge I know the fuck I am
right so have you ever go there again I
never mention it to you my friend owns
the cafeteria and it's a vegetarian
cafeteria but every once in a while he's
a Spanish dude he whips up some badass
shit Lenny yeah yeah man he is weird how
he took over it and I always forget to
tell you about I don't know if you ever
go back to Boulder but if you do check
it out yeah I'll check it out even go on
the web page just look they always have
some fucking genius going through
they're dropping bad ass knowledge
listen if you want to see the stones you
go to the garden if you want to see a
good fight you got a garden if you want
to see a smart
badass motherfucker job balance go to
the rope up really go to Boulder yeah
boulders got some fucking you know we
met look at bro they have elite martial
artists too heavy lead MMA guys in
Boulder they got a flow tank doesn't
have a flow type they have everything in
bold I mean that's an astronaut school
so there's people who have it's amazing
the quality of people I met boulders I
judged mm-hmm that I was like blown away
by now it's a great town you know when
you meet a physicist and he meets a guy
like me he looks down on me and Boulder
those motherfuckers talk and then they
take it back what you went to Yale you
got a fucking master's from Harvard you
know because they're fucking so extreme
just because they're geniuses in that
level doesn't mean they're nerds bro
especially they moved to balls there
might be hunters like a KKK racist
because he was that eccentric Joe you
posted something your day six geniuses
who were perverts yeah
what doesn't bro when you become that
deep I would go to the rope and listen
the Ginsberg is one of the guys I
remember I probably went to four
seminars there to listen to people who
me and everybody had samples on who he
was vegan but I grasp a lot of fuckin
different things man that helped me you
know
I remember going there one time ago
maybe the Catholic religion is bullshit
the way this motherfucker was dropping
it right they weren't asking you to
donate they weren't asking you to join
they didn't want you to be Richard Gere
I know the Dalai Lama was going there
Polly Lama is always swinging in Bolger
or he used this somebody from that tribe
goes to that Naropa now it's very
interesting bro oh and I always forgot
to ask you in your travels anybody ever
approached you and Sam somebody from
Naropa no it's so it's a Buddhist
University look at what is college ready
spell it na ROP a very fucking cool
oh and even that I like the mind of a
fucking thief named Robert University
and they were getting through to me like
I was like wow these fucking people are
cool shit because we you you make
judgment you're like oh this just cuz
this guy went to Harvard or whatever
he's not gonna be interested in smoking
a joint
oh this motherfuckers got a pound in
this suitcase under the microscope you
know like he grew into something you're
like wow yeah um I went to an ashram
when I was in Boulder they were they're
an ashram in the mountains like a Buddha
shop yeah just meditate up there in the
mountains and kill bugs you know
Buddhists are not supposed to kill bugs
so lady had a bug spray I go what are
you doing did she goes we have an ant
problem I go wait a minute you know
you're a Buddhist you're not supposed to
be spraying fucking bugs like that's
like convenient it's very convenient of
you that you spray an ant medication or
ant poison out you're not supposed to do
that
she is yeah well it's very unfortunate
we really have you know cleanliness
issues and this I go listen you're not
supposed to kill fucking ants like
that's half them like how about vegans
that have cats
guess what fuckface you're not a vegan
okay if you have a cat and you're a
vegan and you're feeding your cat cat
food you're feeding your cat murdered
animals you are buying murdered animals
you yourself
you yourself are responsible for the
death of animals period fact Jamie
Kelston all you fucking people that are
vegans and post photos of your cats
those cats are murderers
that's the only thing cats do if you
have a cat and you try to keep feed your
cat beaten vegan cat food they fucking
go blind they start shitting themselves
start walking into walls they don't get
enough protein you can't feed a vegan
capitulation dad they can't they can't
exist like you go to forums like vegan
cat forums it's hilarious because post
after post you see people saying well
I've finally given in and I had to start
feeding my cat regular cat food of
course you did he's a little murderer
you're catching murderers you're a
person who believes that animals
shouldn't die but you're contributing to
those animals dying so that you feed
your animal that kills animals
do you understand how crazy this all is
that highlights the whole hypocrisy of
the idea of not taking life you take
life everybody takes life like take like
takes life life takes life whether you'd
like it or not unfortunately it doesn't
mean that you can't be a really good
person and have a cat and only
contribute to a certain amount of cat
murder because look at these cats eating
your next dirty monsters bread down but
still dirty monsters at heart you you
know the idea behind it is hilarious and
I don't mean to single out the the
reason why I did is because some of the
vegans that I've run into who are these
self-righteous fuckers will take
pictures with their cats like look at
you that's not being a vegan you're bi
you're spending money to get animals
killed that's a fact unless you're out
there like unless you just let your cat
forage for itself then you just live
with a murderer you know you're a vegan
who lives with a murderer but if you're
a vegan around they're buying cat food
guess what dude cuz I actually listen to
vegans it's getting deep with you like
it makes me angry we'll go to war with
ya fuck is gonna war it's got a world
war like Tony Montana Wars what we go to
war against self righteousness that's
what it is it's it's no listen they miss
the big picture look at man when you
work that fear factor I'm sure there was
some really cool people and then there
was some real fucking douchebags when we
went to bowled let me tell you something
man there was some lovely people in
Boulder I meant brilliant brilliant and
then again there's the people who are
there's people out there 60% of these
people that pick up a fucking hobby or
whatever the fuck they call it taha me
bro it's a social activity anymore
religions have become a social activity
you understand me nobody becomes you
know somebody does something that's
because they really believe in it they
really want to do it not anymore dog not
anymore dog people join something just
to be a part of some it's a social
whatever that's a lot of it it's it's
it's it's
associated as a social brownie points in
every day yeah take the high ground I'm
bored I'm lonely what am I gonna do
I got three windows I might be gay I
might save cats you know I was in
Hollywood one day and I'm eating and
there was a guy behind me and he was gay
and I'm like this guy cannot be this gay
Jimmy
Jamie this guy couldn't not be that gay
because nobody is that gay but there are
people not that gay this guy was that
gay like too gay like oh my god the
whole thing the Cologne the scarf around
the neck you know those guys that overdo
it the guy I kidnapped not Vella but the
guy I kidnapped my partner was gonna
kidnap me yes I should stab myself every
day for having him as my partner he had
everything a guy needed to be a guy he
had a pit bull he had a black car with
tinted windows and a loud stereo he had
a motorcycle he had a tattoo he hung out
at strip clubs he was that guy he was
the common guy you know who's your
connection I can't tell you there right
now shut the fuck up you know he was
that guy you know it's the same thing in
life that I see it every day people
they're hobbyists bro mm-hmm their
hobbies this is a hobbyist time until
the next mindfuck comes up you know they
dive into some it's a yoga club they go
there it's it's socially man is socially
god forbid you know walk in the street
anymore then when we were kids you ever
go to a prom what do you call those
parties in college Oh cake party yeah
whatever you got a cake party how they
salute you people with the label so
coasters got the big you can't see a
label they shake your hand it's a good
thing go and walk the streets in the
morning so they're holding up a label to
let you know they're in a certain group
I'm in the type of I'm drinking a Pabst
Blue Ribbon okay but now it's turned
into Starbucks god forbid a human being
doesn't have a Starbucks cup in their
hand by 8 o'clock in this society
god forbid of you working in an office
and six people every day walking with a
mocha soy almond you know gluten free
sperm free fuck up a lot
god forbid the guy who walks in with a
7-eleven cup of coffee right he's a
loser it's pretty poor we all have to
fucking have that Starbucks cup you know
there's Starbucks that fucking great
really well you know what dream it says
these days when you I mean nothing wrong
with coffee but what a lot of people are
buying it's like a super sweet shake
you're buying a super sweet shake that
has caffeine is whipped cream in it and
fucking all those those venti things
that people buy those blended things ice
blended vanilla soy your it's a shake
shake with drugs in it offense no girl
from Jersey give me that motherfucker
black because white girl from black is
beautiful I can give it get don't touch
that when you go to Jersey the mornings
you drove a limo you know what it's like
when you going can you imagine going to
your diner and boss you know what let me
get some soy milk they would throw that
fucking black coffee at you for 2,000
years America drank a fucking
from a cup that looked like a bowling
ball like a helmet that they put yeah
got it would you sit the regular
grown-up cream and sugar little bit of
cream of the cream sugar white whatever
that's it if you go to Dunkin Donuts you
ask for a regular coffee they give it to
you with cream and sugar
come on yeah today so yeah for sure yeah
ask for it like this places we can go to
this day you have a regular coffee to
pour the cream in for you pour a couple
dashes of sugar for 36,000 years
Americans ate a butter roll every
motherfucking East Coast hate a butter
roll that's it
fuck the egg fuck the gluten fuck the
protein angles with butter bagels are
but I don't want every fucking corner
well York City would have liked but it
would sell those Bret wrapped up rolls
with with butter already buttered or
wrapped up bagels already buttered
fucking amazing yeah I just needed some
calories no but now it's like if you
don't have a Starbucks fucking coffee so
that lady you met in bold because let me
tell you one thing about bold I believe
bold ahead a lot bolder specializes in
one thing they specialize if you're
serious about your health and your life
the value of your life people who value
their lives like somebody lives in a big
city and one day he has a heart
I got 33 and he's a stockbroker yeah
he's got 30 million dollars in the man
but he's fucking 33 those guys when they
though it's over and they moved to bone
they open up a bookstore
you don't know you walk by there and go
how does this fucking look make a living
it's people who wanted a head still
lives and people realize you don't have
to be around as many goddamn people I
did Kevin and bean yesterday so I was up
at 5:50 I was in my car by 6 a.m.
driving on the highway packed packed
fucking 30 miles an hour going down the
101 it's six o'clock in the morning it
was it's madness god forbid you get
there at 7:30 or 8:00 it's death it's
hot death for a dozen miles and there's
too many motherfuckers man it's not good
for you it's not good for you if you
have to live here I totally understand
but you and I don't we don't deliver
we're on the road all the time I'm gonna
start Skype and shit in I'm gonna put
Jamie and a goddamn fish tank and I'm
gonna start skyping from the middle of
nowhere I'm gonna figure out how to do
that Ari Shaffir does that when he does
that punch-drunk podcast he's on he's in
New York and they're over here they
skypes these guys in a little corner a
little fucking square amazing how if
when I get on a plane
when I travel I get I get the 6 a.m.
because let me tell you something bro
and you know look at me and say no way
there's a huge difference on the 405
from 10:00 to 6:00 and 10:00 after 6:00
it's miraculous oh yeah it's something
you've never seen and I'll do it with
you I go there five days in the camera
go you ready
that's ten to six you see it moving yeah
watch ten after six Clank Clank look at
that HOV Lane look at that motherfucker
stop yeah stopped HOV nines
motherfuckers in the car stop no man I
get in that fucking car at 4:45 the
owner takes me 20 minutes to get the
fucker on the 405 at 4:00 and 5:00 in
the morning oh yeah when he finds
nothing it's beautiful in your city 4:00
in the morning it's beautiful I believe
I get to the fucking Airport I park in
the 3 right by the elevator I love it
you know what I do sometimes if I got a
wild hair at my ass I'll take my car up
into the mountains like you ever go up a
Angeles Crest Highway Angeles Crest
Highway off the 210 if you go off the
210 and like driving from
like this studio towards Pasadena if you
went up through the 118 to the 210
there's an area called the Angeles Crest
Highway and you take it up into the
mountains just a two-lane road if you go
up there like five o'clock in the
morning six o'clock at the mall gets
fucking dead empty and bright when the
Sun start to come up
just drive just drive up there just
drive up there and see the mountains and
the hills and there's not fuckin soul in
sight when you could do that when you
can get on the highway and you see like
one car a mile up and one car like a
mile back and that's it just you three
motherfuckers and if one guy going this
way one go it's like relaxing it gives
you a feeling of peace because you're so
constantly concentrating on all these
motherfuckers this guy next using a
truck and this guy next to you is kind
of weaving in that of lanes and this
motherfucker in front of you is going
too slow and it's like it's so much shit
to think about when you could just get
on a highway
there's nobody it's a peaceful feeling
you just go you forget driving is nice
remember when you were a little kid you
first got your driver's license and
you're like whoohoo little kid but you
know 18 whatever you first get to
remember ledge of four-year-olds was
driving like driving is fun like my
six-year-old she's learning how to ride
a bike
so I'm teaching her ride a bike without
training wheel so we're moving around
showing how to do tight turns and stuff
and she's having the time of her life
and I'm thinking if I had to drive a
bike in this little fucking house
driveway I would be so bored but to a
six-year-old it's like whoo it's so fun
that's what it's like when you first
start driving a car it's fun and you
forget like driving a car just is a
pleasure if you have a car that works
right and you're out on a nice road and
there's no one there the music's a
beautiful view a beautiful view to look
at it that's the thing that really gets
me about Colorado more than anything is
the sheer beauty of the landscape
Boulder like how about evergreen when
you're driving from evergreen down into
Denver people know about evergreen every
is a half an hour outside of Denver you
might as well be on that mountain man TV
show you might as well be one of those
fucking dudes that makes their own would
you you're up there in the middle of the
fucking mountain 30 minutes from Denver
beautiful
I remember the last time I had peace of
mind was I was shooting a Longest Yard
and I was walking on Saturdays and
Sundays and they opted they said you
need to go home we'll stay I would stay
in the hotel the hotel would be empty
it'd be a couple of us I would stay down
there and I would get the rental car dog
and I would get on that road like go to
Taos oh yeah drive to all those place
I'd stop and get a green chile that's
are hippies right Tao Oh hippies like
turn the fucking car around 3-4 hours no
traffic no traffic
I just gotta know whatever road I don't
know what it was that you ever do that
drive from San Diego to Vegas
fuck yeah that's a nice Drive that's
that's beautiful when you go through
those weird desert areas and you get to
see those I went to the the Air Force
Base I forget which base it is down
there where the Blue Angels are I did
the name of it but I had a drive down
San Diego and then from San Diego I had
to go across like quite a while to to
get to this Air Force Base where they
took me on a flight with the Blue Angels
and you're driving through these desert
areas where these beautiful rock
formations and shit it's gorgeous out
there just go as long as you have AC
it's fucking gorgeous like seeing the
cool rock structures and shit it's a
pleasure you know people forget you we
live here in LA and we associate driving
with being a pain in the ass whoo sad is
that sad it's like it's fucking like you
like wake up the morning your feet touch
you like fuck I gotta go to Hollywood at
2:30
god dammit god fucking damn it you'll
start looking at you get on the phone
you put on Channel five and they're
telling you the 101 there's an accent on
the way here bro I left my house at
fucking 10:20 I could have been here
early yeah yeah fucking car flipped on
the other side as I was driving the
people hanging by their fucking
seatbelts I mean it was that far left
when I was in my far left Wow so I got
to see it and three motherfuckers out
with their fucking cameras with TMZ
course Jesus Christ Joe Rogan that's
that's justifiable homicide where I come
from
double homicide to shoot him right there
pull over what is wrong with you
somebody's
for their life and you have your fucking
camera on you miserable motherfucker
and there was people getting out of
their cars helping them I mean it was
bumper-to-bumper I don't know how the
fucking ambience is gonna get it yeah
well that's sometimes we'll have to type
welcome to the fucking world the canvas
my friends yeah yeah Oh somebody's
yelling for their life you're gonna
fucking camera on for love of Christ
what kind of goddamn human being a you a
just to extend your hands for the person
to see you you know what's fucked up
though you talked to them and they're
nice guys look Vlad those TMZ camera
guys those guys are very nice guy I'll
even know if it was the TMZ guy there
were three people three there was two
people with cell phones and a guy had
like a little fun right I was like well
some people are just filming it cuz
they're there they had to have mean some
people if they have something on them
that can record they have to record
things oh my god I can't believe it and
we get this on video but those a lot of
these guys are just guys who have a job
it's the real problem is that people
want to read that shit you know that's
the real problem
including us it's compelling you find
out about some crazy story some nutty
shit happen TMZ has a video of it you
don't go to it ever no TMZ if we used to
watch it two three years ago it's a six
o'clock now I just watch the news if
there's something something fucking
completely crazy happens you're gonna
you know people are gonna want to see it
they're gonna want to see a video I
think I went to subway look whatever got
knocked out I was curious
oh oh oh yeah the valet guy knocked
about um record producer you know not
Puff Daddy but the guy for the West
Coast rap I know he always talked about
yeah yeah Suge Knight sorry yeah a
barber knocked him out right some some
dude one two barbershop in LA he was a
valet right I don't think so
he was out of that one guy yeah o out of
Valley I don't remember exactly what
happened but yeah yeah just we live in a
weird world see those videos all the
time every day there's new ones every
day this is some new thing
Jamie watches all that shit every time I
come in here is motherfuckers got some
new Beyonce story for me I always find
out lately I found out about the ti
what happened they buy the fuck out of
Mayweather I never saw that but there
would be such the videos online you know
T I went on opening
and for that who's fuckin hilarious he's
really funny it's like a real relaxed
dude
he's a fun dude was it Justin - mmm I
don't know I just I mean I don't even
know if the video or the appearance on
Opie and Anthony was after that fight I
was just in my car and they were talking
and you know you look at the serious it
shows you who the the guest isn't it
said Ti it was fun it's fun guy man look
think he's having a good time with them
I watched it didn't he get busted with
guns yes okay he looks like a fun guy he
did movie he's an American fucking
gangster he was an American gangster
yeah he's the basement ends on
Washington yeah he's the one that was
the baseball player that he got him a
tryout with the Yankees is show up and
that Denzel was up - goes how come you
didn't show up because I'm gonna play
baseball for I won't be like you oh
that's funny
did you see the ads for the new James
Brown movie they got a James Brown movie
whose plays a zebra I don't know some
dude I don't know here let's pull it up
Brown movie I went to see the Tom Cruise
movie last night tomorrow it's fucking
great
that movie is great it's really good man
it's called get on up get up get on up
the dude's name is Chadwick Boseman
hmm do you know what it is Chadwick
Boseman okay handsome fella it's been a
bunch of shit he's been he was on All My
Children
haha no way since 1970 must be a
different guy it was James Brown the
movie comes off Chadwick Boseman it came
out he can't be it says All My Children
1970 it's got to be a different Chadwick
Bowman you dummies that doesn't make any
sense the guys he's not that old maybe
it was a kid on the show they know he's
not even that wouldn't mean he would
have to be what 40-something years old
no way so the movie came out already
no no no no no it's not yeah
it's the the ads for it right now he was
in that movie 42 he played Jackie Robin
oh that dudes badass okay yeah yeah yeah
that was a good movie you know I heard
it was really good that kid was good he
was very good you know who's good in
that movie you know who was fucking
bad-ass in that movie dawg
Harrison fucking Foy oh yeah damn he was
in disguise he dropped it on me I mean
he says some shit that you like look at
fucking Harrison Ford selling it isn't
interesting this dudes playing two
famous dead black dudes like Jackie
Robinson and then tan he's their go-to
guy sure sure this is a motherfucker you
gotta do what you got to do sometimes
don't get up that fucking Tom Cruise
movie is good man I'm telling you is one
of the most original science fiction
movies ever seen his ray I had low
expectations I went into it I thought it
was gonna be some shoot him up where Tom
Cruise does the standard shit and every
one of them he's standard you know like
calm cool collected you know facing the
adversity know it was a complex
character that he had a play and the
movie was very complex it was there was
a lot going on it's like about time
travel that this part of the movie is an
alien movie an alien invasion movie
about time travel I can't tell you
anymore I'll give you a spoiler alert
but it's fucking good movie man there's
a good fucking movie look I'd give it a
9 out of 10 there's a really good movie
like one of the most original science
fiction movies I've ever seen you see in
3d no no I just tell regular come on
wearing glasses I don't give a shit
movie king of New York yeah great movie
by the year again super walking
Constantine rain this dude on Twitter
told me that my fuck that movies
overrated as fuck it was on the other
eye holy shit you're a little bit to me
he didn't do it
I mean Christopher walk is always
Christopher Walken right Laurence
Fishburne stole that motherfucker
Laurence Fishburne stole that
motherfucker
listen I come to the conclusion that
he's the best black actor now and I'll
prove it to you you know when when he
beats to check in the movie Tina Turner
he plays a different type of black dude
don't make me say it
mm-hmm and then whenever he plays a
completely different type of black dude
but the opening of that movie he goes to
King Tito's house and to buy the coke
with Steve Buscemi and Steve Buscemi's
will he call that shit weighing out the
coke making sure it's good and fucking
Laurence Fishburne is torturing this
drug-dealing yo you play ball nuttin
by looking at you you got a coke and he
keeps torturing them torch them and then
finally the guy you what the fucking
drugs you fucking black guy I don't do
business and he gives him the thing and
the guy's about to open up the briefcase
to check the money and he fucking slams
he goes where's my motherfucking took
which is classic and he finally opens it
up and it's all tampons and he goes what
the fuck is this to plug your
motherfucking holes and he shoots him in
the black bag comes to room service and
they start shooting people that's the
best opening to any fucking movie I've
seen I forgot all about that movie i sat
there going what the fuck is this
tremendous yeah tremendous I recommend
if you haven't seen in a long time
Christopher Walken with news in that
movie dog the black dude from lost
he's the kid on the elevator that goes
to mug Christopher Walken Christopher
Walken throws him like 10,000 goes come
see me I'll give you a job they look at
the money they take off that's the
little black dude from lost that was
also he's in a thousand things he was a
young kid really like a young kid like
you know 2018 no shit it's amazing when
you see these old movies are you like
wow look what the fuck that is play him
one scene like in the thief
Manhunter that dude that was CSI for 18
years that dude was on the dude from Los
was on he was on the fucking the prison
movie the prison he was an oz Tosh -
yeah the guy in the wheelchair yeah fuck
yeah how about Laurence Fishburne he was
in fucking Apocalypse Now
dawg I talked to him one day you're full
of a fucking weed store no shadow he was
talking about how he was 14 and he had
to bring his mother down it cuz they
shot down the Philippines they were
there for a year bro Wow he was a kid
well on that boat he was 14 years old 15
years old yeah he was really young and
that movie took a long time to film two
years studios and Marlon Brando was on
that so Marlon Brando this what this
motherfucker did they met went under
like Marlon we love you but get it
together
your little getting a little heavy
you're playing a fucking major
you're playing a guy who parachutes out
of planes please work out how much the
trailer caught give him a check for a
trainer Willie one ten thousand give me
twenty hit the best trainer lose the way
Mahler took the check absolutely dog
post time fucking showed up twenty
pounds overweight than what he was at
the meeting they were furious that's why
all the scenes are dark yeah that's why
the only show is head shit holding his
head they never show this body then
that's why cuz they were like dog what
the fuck we gave you money for a trainer
dog I spent the money at Spago's didn't
he have an island at one point in time
tonight listen if you're into this shit
cuz I'm into stupidity okay me and Joe
Rogan chase Coburn on Sunset Boulevard
I'm into those old actors they
represented something different they
represented Marlon Brando represented
something completely different in my
eyes this kid was from Nebraska
this kid was from fucking Nebraska you
know it'd be stuck on James Dean focus
on fucking Brandon this guy came out
here and just fuck people up and they
hated them they hated him you know he
wrote a hilarious fuckin letter to
Charlie Sheen when he couldn't make his
birthday party he wrote dear Charlie I'm
feeling like a very large turd on a very
thin stick I'm holed up in bed and
taking everything from sled dog urine to
Powerade power power D I don't know
Eastern Indian vulva maybe won't work
tomorrow if I feel the same that's what
he sent him when he was thinking about
not going to his party that's where you
was out there they didn't want for the
Godfather you know I had a push man for
the Godfather I was crazy he didn't give
a fuck and then he showed up they know
the fuck he was he put the cotton in his
mouth this shit and he just blew my
little water then they gave him great no
before that the game what's that movie
did we cost the studio 80,000 he was
directing whatever the fuck about the
boat dawg yeah yeah anyway they went
down there and they realized they get
that they're like was Marlon Brando he's
in the hut fuckin six fucking Hawaiian
chicks that's what he married
he was a crazy mother was crazy
motherfucker and then he came back dog
and he just he then he sent an Indian to
the fucking Oscars to protest yeah the
fucking American movies does this shit
and at the end of his life he didn't he
live he mean he lived on an island or
something right did he do some point I
think you live in Studio City I sweat
yeah he lived around here it wasn't yeah
he lived around here at the island he
lost the island he lost the island but
that was also a tragic side he lost his
kids it was very sad that whole thing
will happen
well you can't imagine the guy like that
would be really good at taking care of
kids you know what he was really bad at
acid I didn't realize it cuz I didn't
listen I have to watch it cuz my wife
watches the Man of Steel oh that movie
yeah movie but I love Cameron Crowe but
not good Marlon Brando cemented that
role so strong that speech he tells him
before he puts them in the fucking thing
bro yeah that's we had to be Superman if
your father tells you the speech if your
father looking I tell you that speech
you gotta be Superman that's it you're
like that you just blew my fucking mind
it was amazing
he had a lease of an island 1966 he got
a 99 year lease the island of this I
don't know how to say this bitch te TI a
are Oh a Tet dro but Tahiti government
making him its sole owner 35 miles from
the main island of Tahiti it's a group
of thirteen islets small islands
measuring about 27 square miles and
surrounded by a lagoon fucking dude
lived up there an eco resort Wow
crazy man strange strange dude man you
know there's a rumor he's a charge to
read your script he's to charge you to
read your script no like a view my
studio said high boiling we have a
script for you okay 50 G's he would bang
you at every level that makes sense
though if you're Marlon fucking Brando
bang you know 45 to read the screen oh
you want me to come off the island for
I have her because your Ellen Ellen well
that's when you're a bad motherfucker
when they're willing to fly into an
island talk to and if you wanted to fly
him off it would cost you like triple to
fly off the island yeah like oh no we
want you to come to Hollywood show up
with his crazy hat on but apparently he
would sign up to do movies too it hadn't
read it at all and would make them put
up these big placards with all the lines
that he had to say like right behind him
as you just freeball it on the side I
don't know I think that the Americans I
think people itself sometimes take
acting too sacred Zee you know mmm but
if like if the Godfather the scene where
he's at the table he's talking about if
something should happen to my son he
gets up that's what they said he was
reading off the guys lapels his shit
yeah but look at them see if you see him
reading yeah at the end maybe 1972 when
he was dropped by God the Godfather's
gonna need to be oversmart hey tell you
the boy you know me I get up at 6:00 I'm
watch the news or something Godfather I
gotta catch 10 minutes of it last night
I watched the scene when he told
what's-his-name he was out he was
brilliant bro he told the constantly
arey the white do it right he tells him
when he goes were going to Vegas he just
got out of the hospital he goes you know
hear any smacks because no offense let
Michael I'm gonna do this and he goes
but I can help you Michael goes you're
out he gets up and leaves he's beautiful
girl he's beautiful so no matter if he
was reading cards is shit you know we
forget you forget probably if we forget
because we were subjected to such bad
fucking movies but I watched that movie
again here then I don't watch him pieces
I don't have the time to sit and watch
three hours but it's been on HBO and I
wants to see when he comes down he tells
the Val cars are coming to my house tell
you two vowels another one who's crazy
you know tell you dawn what everybody
seems to know and he goes but I was
about to but you had to have a drink Hey
to drink out of his hands because now
you had your drink I get goose bumps
I've seen that scene a hundred times I
still get goose bumps bro well he looks
at Sonny it flows that curtain down on
that table
he tells that dude look how they
massacred my son are you fucking kidding
me
are you fucking kidding me yet good get
the guy from mangling Gangs of New York
he'll take that guy and break up and
fucking half by his neck like a chicken
at that time that dude was dropping it
on you with cue cards whatever didn't
matter
it didn't matter he knew who the fuck he
wasn't away in there you know what's
interesting man Last Tango in Paris
that's what's interesting then even a
funky Bordeaux after that really yeah is
porno-y say is a porn it was this close
to pull it as could be they really look
at that could look at the poster for it
I'm looking at it's like nine and a half
weeks kind of porn yeah it's him in some
broad making out in this thing
italian-american franco-italian romantic
erotic drama wow I never saw that he's
crazy
that too he puts light bulbs in a pussy
the original battery the traitor a
recent American widower who begins an
anonymous sexual relationship with a
young betrothed Parisian woman Marlon
Brando Moriya shrine Eider who's Maria
Schneider whoa still alive alive and
kickin nope died
58 2011 and Patti died in pati 58 not
that old
Wow you know it's interesting I was
gonna say that some movies like The
Godfather holds up perfect
The Godfather could be in the movies
today it would seem a little unusual
because the way it's sort of filmed and
framed and the music in it and
everything like that it would be like it
would stand out as being unusual but it
would totally hold up but other movies
from that era big movies that you really
enjoyed from that era dog show French
Connection you want to shoot
it's really bad yeah except for the ball
when he shakes everybody down Popeye
doesn't he
what the fuck is this he makes the
milkshake yeah that's all really good
but everything else the mechanic drags
any Charles Bronson movie want to shoot
yourself really it's brutal
even even high high times holds up you
know high mechanic try to watch The
Godfather I never watch any of them your
wife
don't look at Jan Michael Vincent died
for about 20 minutes
he's an example of a guy who fell apart
nobody know America doesn't know the
beauty of a man because remember Jan
Michael Vincent Lee kept it together
Richard Gere was still been jumping down
with fucking Hindus and fucking Baghdad
whatever the fuck he was he's a Buddhist
Richard Gere big time there would have
been no reaching here cuz he was blond
long he was about to kill it he killed
it with the world's greatest athlete but
when we were kids Nizhny he picked up
the fucking weights and his arm stayed
there yeah he was that he played uh but
that was all he played a movie called
defiance where he's a longshoreman and
on the west side with Paulie walnuts or
The Sopranos Danny Aiello and again they
attack the fucking a gang like a Mexican
Puerto Rican gang that movie was on HBO
for a while but that movie that mechanic
is slow as fuck when they go to Italy
that slow is fucked through when they go
to Italy he was born in Denver Colorado
he's still alive Jan Michael Vincent
still alive just amazing 69 years old
with no fucking kidneys a liver that
love fuckers just in that crazy though
Last Tango in Paris chick Denis fuck Jan
Michael Vincent pickled drunky shit gold
teeth still kicking yeah man he's he's
fucking apparently he's got some issues
too he left Hollywood 12 years ago for a
life on the Mississippi Delta that's
where he lives now gas gotta be a weird
ride man not everybody's cut out for
that kind of movie star Tom Cruise type
shit it's crazy is that Tom Cruise
motherfucker is keeps it together pretty
goddamn good I mean I'm sure if you talk
to one of his
ex-wives they would say they would tell
you some horror story
well people and fucking crazy outfits
you know tell him about Xenu up on a
planet pluton or some shit that's
controlling Tom's vibrations forcing him
to recite the doctrine of Scientology
but if you look at like what he's done
and the fact that he's still alive and
kicking from go back to like what was
that first movie just take this what
movie was that big go from risky
business to today in 2014
Tom Cruise is still knocking it out of
the park as a movie star you know why I
wrote Scientology beside Scientology
he's as well prepared as you are as gay
he's on top of his game you know that
you can't be fucking around and getting
20 million a move you fucking around
he's on top of his game you know what
bro he's got some movies that you watch
them and go yeah this sucks but go yeah
he went from risky business and all a
sudden he rocked against Jack Nicholson
in that movie with the marine movie
what's the name of that fucking movie oh
yeah if you could man oh well that rock
did that and then he rocked this fucking
Jerry Maguire I mean he hit it out of
the fucking park as an agent but dog
when you watch that fucking movie where
he plays the Hitman with Jamie Foxx oh
yeah he goes into the Japanese bar it
was Koreatown and he starts shooting
motherfuckers look at his legs
mmm what'd he shoot that's military
that's military style shoot you just
don't make that up here Scientologist so
that means for three weeks before that
he went to work somewhere he was
beautiful that movie he was beautiful in
that scene all the guys who've ever done
those movies he's the most consistent
like he does his own stunts his own race
cars all that shit and you know what I'm
sorry to tell you he's a tiny dude Ricky
Cruz played his double and the movie
where he said that was horrendously bad
movie yeah yeah oh the Sunset Strip
aleena Rockstar Baldwin and all those
people I heard that was all they said
was the kiss of death
Ricky Cruz played his double his eyes
and it by Hardee's is not I heard it's
an exaggeration but not that tiny I
heard that they actually build sets
where it's bigger so he can stand on say
yes well they did that with him and Brad
Pitt when him and Brad Pitt did
interview with the vampire Brad Pitt
talked about how they would walk and Tom
Cruise would walk next to him on like a
ramp so like Brad Pitt would walk here
and Tom Cruise would walk next to him on
a ramp because he had to be the same
height as him I bet they do that for a
lot of movies though cuz I have these
you know leads that he like the
actresses they can't have what the
actors being taller than him so that's
weird
but it's well it's weird that that
hasn't liked him hampered him you know
in any way he's still like one of the
main movie stars he rocks the house
rocks the house he rocked the house and
this I'm telling you Joey go see this
guy this guy you know have to some but
there's some people of this field on
DiCaprio that's not elope - he's crazy
right he's crazy does it he does it to
get that tenant big everyone busy yeah
he said new dog shits broke right he
can't control that CAA calls him guess
what we have a movie about a bar you're
gonna be great next you know he's tap
dancing I'm sure while they giving them
envelopes it's okay after he goes to the
fucking screen in five seven see he's
five seven and Ving Rhames is actually
six foot but this is a good example
where they're trying to make him look I
don't think he's five seven I think
that's a lie I think that's one of those
Napoleon things you know everybody talks
about Napoleon being short you know the
Polian was like above average height for
the time he wasn't short it was England
fucking with them they would do all
these jokes about Napoleon being short
he was five six back then people were
tiny shit so like five six back then was
like normal size dude is this the same
website you keep pulling up CollegeHumor
I don't know if they substantiate all
the other websites also said five seven
really yeah five seven here's here's one
with Tom Cruise yeah five seven Diaz
five seven see how they're making him
like they're constantly always making
him talk even though like these people
are weighted him oh so they're standing
on something yeah like buckets and stuff
yeah it says wouldn't be funny if he's
actually six feet tall but this is just
a giant troll that everybody's saying
he's five seven
five seven five seven yeah oh he's
walking next to people well Katie Holmes
was giant like what they would go out in
public Katie Holmes was like
legitimately like five ten right wasn't
she
no I think she's kind of a young girl
all right what a girl oh she is she's
five nine yeah but so was Nicole Kidman
Nicole Kidman was big too oh say what's
going on there's yeah well there's dudes
who wear stuff in their shoes you know
and she's Rogers big too right yeah
Rogers he slung some dick dawg maybe
whatever he did he figured out how to
get all these girls to marry him this
you know what we'll never get the full
story because Scientology is so
secretive and inclusive and you know so
so culty but what a fascinating story
that would be see like if I mean the
rumors are all true if he really is a
closeted gay guy that it has arranged
marriages and they go on for 10 years
and the women get all this money and you
know he needs them because this is like
the image that he's trying to portray
that's a fast listen so a big place
because I was thinking about their look
at what happened honestly how many
meetings could you go up and say to
yourself I can make a fucking killing if
I could get my phone to tape a beating
of we don't seem like a Scientology
party what it really is right it's like
Travolta and fucking Tom Cruise bikinis
guys it was somebody with sell a four
hundred billion dollar bill II though
well you know you're seeing that now
with certain guys like this Bryan Singer
guy that directs the x-men that this is
the guy that is in trouble because his
one of his ex-boyfriends was claiming
that he was sexually exploited and they
passed him around holy shit they have
fucking parties let me tell you
something no hate gave motherfuckers
know how to party they know how if they
know how to party
these guys have this fucking - his
photos pull up some photos of Bryan
Singer's parties
he has parties or he has a red lights in
the swimming pool and they're filled
with twinks this it's it's a twink soup
and everyone is dancing around the pool
the pools it's flooded by guys with no
shirts on and they're all touching each
other and having a great fucking time
and if you're
okay that gun that's got to be the wit
look at this that's the way to fucking
party why not
what is everybody angry yeah what's
twigs twinks twinks are like little
skinny gay guys that look you know kind
of like boyish that's life that's a type
yeah super twink ain't super Twain but
like look at this what is wrong with
this this looks like a super positive
scene to me I don't have any problem
with anything I see here I see a bunch
of guys doing what they want to do their
pants off they're hanging around in a
pool who is she why's the water brown no
that's yeah it's just blood water it's
from all that ass sex no yeah no don't
do there's a light in the pool it's
lights you see in the corner you see the
red light it's obvious there's lights
it's why is it red light bulbs listen
guy Bryan Singer he's been around for a
while
yeah directed before right directed a
lot of movies like what like x-men did a
lot of experts like two years ago right
no he's done I think is that quite a few
of them right hasn't he he's done a
bunch of shit let's do Bryan Singer
let's pull it up yeah isn't there's a
like that one guy that was suing because
he's getting because he was like the guy
that got passed around by all the guys
yeah but you know what man here's the
deal if you show up for one of those
things and you get passed around like
what the hell I gotta get out of here
this is a bad situation
have you keeps showing up but you keep
getting passed around then you want to
write a book about it I don't know you
could have left you got a co-star part
you got fucked in the ass 82 times yeah
that's it that's what you listen and I
could see that happening in Hollywood it
happens to women all the time guys they
go to these fucking parties don't know
what type of parties there are next you
know they're in the Hollywood Hills that
doing fucking roofies then doing blow
and there's eight fucking young guys
fuck and it happens have I been to one
no it happens it has to happen little
young guys for the confused here they
come from a small town they gay they go
to an audition Bryan Singer contact some
I want to fuck you personally you know
let's do lunch next thing you know
you're at a fucking pool and let's go
let's go upstairs how we can't even
believe it and that you know you you
watch that movie with Tom Cruise one of
the darkest movies he made fuckers great
movie bro what's moving with all the
masks
yes I wish that's always on late night
why st. Bryan Singer because would I
compare that situation like you bet yeah
not Stanley Kubrick but that's who I
should wear a bunch of old guys they're
fucking yes and once a month they go to
a house red band tells me to call a
phone and say red devil
and he sends you to a house in the hills
a car picks you up you don't even know
where you're going how fucking creepy
and they take it to a house and there's
a fucking hundred tents walking around
with masks on naked naked and you're
doing the sacrilegious shit with drums
with a robe on which means you're gonna
fuck somebody in the ass til they die
member Oh Tom Cruise is fucking the
chicken she was on coke and she took her
in the doctor was Sydney Pollack
nobody fucking remembers here would you
remember that movie at all that's a
fucking dark man would happen a good
movie bro what happens is the coke
kidney fucks with him let me tell you
some I never thought Nicole Kidman was
shit cuz I was that moon Nicole Kidman
eats him up and spits him alive like
with this accent she starts to tell him
about there once was a time where I went
to this thing with this army guy you
were a man like he starts to tell him he
wasn't a man but that she went and this
guy that a navy guy so he got so mad he
started getting a cab and he kept seeing
spots of this fucking guy just ramming
the coke Kidman black-and-white footage
in your head of this guy with a navy hat
just blaster and finally he goes to get
a hooker she's missing a something so he
goes into an Arabian this dude to get a
because he goes to see his buddy was the
piano play I think I goes no no no I got
a I got a gig I can't tell you about he
tells him about the gig he was you gotta
wear a cape and a top hat so this dude
has to go to a fucking costume store
midnight wakes up the guy but when he
wakes up the guy to rent the costume
they hear something and they go in the
room and the guy the costume guy has a
daughter who's 15 and she's getting
fucked by two Japanese guys with wigs
and mascara on and pink shit on their
faces
this is darker than fuck and Tom Cruise
walks in the middle of this and pop my
ball off so he's like what the fuck's
going on and he takes a cab to this
place he gives the cab 200
and he walks in he sees all these naked
woman he tells him the code word and
having its fucking dog he goes in there
and said the pilot then the next day he
goes looking for a piano guy and the
piano guys missing John cuz they go up
to Tom Cruise during the thing they go
we know who you are we're advising to
get the hell out of here the next day
the piano player is gone
done finito he goes back to the costume
store and returned the stuff one thing
leads to another guy goes oh no you're
missing the boat on and all of a sudden
after all the yelling of screaming when
she caught the fucking guy with the
Japanese guys the girl comes walking out
of the back with the two Japanese guys
our business suits on so he thinks he's
are the fucking it's an awesome my fuck
if you could sit it out Stanley Kubrick
was a bad what's a bad motherfucker that
movie took like three years to release
there was something kinky about that
movie Kubrick was dying but the
co-payment is where's a pair of regular
panties with a wife beater on with those
little titties dog what I mean with
little titties turn you on when those
two little beavers are up and she's
falling like a fucking faggot to his
face and like you're a fucking faggot I
dream with his Navy guy fucking taking
me down and breathing on my neck I could
smell his breath and he's like breaking
inside he goes really why are we going
to sling some dick he's a doctor there
she is right there look at that little
titties that's ace get up and fucking
come on these little fucking fucking
hand balled up and pull up behind the
fucking hand I think you dragged her
into look at that look at that little
red the fucking with Australia little
monkey it smells like an alligator look
at that look at those little bony hips
you know how good they fuck when I'm
sucking that fucking monster wow those
hips are popping up forget about it Oh
ROS Wednesday look a lot that chick is
bagging I need to get that on my iPad
tonight guys watch oh yeah that's one of
those movies I probably need to re-watch
because I remember I didn't like it the
first time but every woman in that in
that scene he does blow with the chick
or she does blow he brings a there's
family love that motherfuckers crazy
said they Paula
you know he's like she dead or some shit
or whatever I'm a doctor what's wrong
with you you're losing it it didn't get
a good good review no no cuz it was
Stanley you know it was dark dog yeah
they say what a what a Stanley's other
movies real quick 2001 Space Odyssey
space sign of see but he's got another
one great Clockwork Orange
she's got movies yeah what's another
Stanley oh yeah Full Metal Jacket that's
the shit okay yeah that's fucking dark
oh yeah shit brilliant what is it that's
a brilliant movie jelly doughnut yeah
called the pile you know that's the best
army movie ever
Full Metal Jacket is there a better army
movie Apocalypse Now is up there too
it's R up there it's up there but I
think full metal jackets better I think
it might be better fish it's right up
there platoon that's up there too is up
there to save imply a private Ryan's up
there to that opening scene man yeah I
can hit that that is as real as a
fucking war scene gets there's no heart
was beating up a fucking store and that
fucking you know movie isn't bad when I
watch them what's the one went down
whatever Black Hawk Down yeah never saw
it it's great maybe you've never seen
Black Hawk Down no tell me it's not a
publishable to be that fucking opening
scene with Martin Sheen in Apocalypse
Now well he's narrating here and he's
like I'm waiting for a bit that door I
went to see that movie on double barrel
sunshine acid with John Crowley DD
Cantera and Kurt delorenzo and we were
out there waiting to go in and there was
a Carvel next to the place I don't
forget this Joe Road
I was tripping my balls off and there
was a Carvel next to his movie theater
there was a it was the second it was a
midnight showing in Apocalypse Now
yeah just come on on Friday there's a
big night in high school it's been that
on double barrel sunshine acid burn it
burn it with your eyes are burning
you're seeing shit and we'll wait Nile
and there's an ice-cream cone that's
tipped over that somebody went to the
movie theater and tipped it over and
then hands on it and my friend john
crowley picked it up and started eating
I thought I was in the fucking die and
they were waiting for the midnight show
at 16 years old whatever the fuck I was
and watched Apocalypse Now and asked it
I thought of a fucking
I don't got scene where they start
shooting arrows out yeah how the fucking
woman that's another movie I don't sleep
on that and forget the redux I like to
read ducks when they show up in France
and eat with the people that's okay
but it takes you away from the fucking
path I like your what they released
because it's straight the redux is good
for a little while the body is the
French guy
they all have dinner at that table but I
really like the fucking original these
are like the redux because it just got
surrounded see yes I don't want it's
three and a half hours sometimes a
little extra something is not what you
need that movie had they cut that movie
a certain fucking way yeah the movie was
creepy bro it was creepy there was parts
of that movie where you feel creeped the
fuck out you don't else I saw a couple
weeks ago that you haven't seen Joe
Rogan Midnight Express great fucking
movie well he bites that motherfuckers
tongues out you shitty stand there and
he's covered fucking blood and they're
all fucking tremendous they just that
was the first time I ever saw a movie
where a guy got arrested in another
country and I was like oh don't get
another country especially for drugs
oh yeah well they took his clothes done
he had the envelope stuck to his body
you feel it your hearts beat because the
director and he's got the guns all
around him and they take him in a they
don't pimp the teeth yeah somebody
fucked he became gay man became Kenny
became gay there and then that's when
the guy kept fucking up with a guy hug
his friends cat and once he woke them
and seen the cat hang the guy went nuts
because you charges for fucked up tea
don't sell his hash he just starts
beating that's one of the greatest beats
of all time remember he's kicking up the
guys under the sink crawling he's
bleeding he's begging for his life and
he's just fucking losing he's been in
his fucking foreign country
he's been lied to they game 80 years
you're dying and I'm dying to
and he's kicking him these keys kick
them and finally got calls out he's got
like one eye left he fucking grabs him
and he fucked because he's a rat he
fucking mugs him and he takes his
fucking tongue he breaks it out and they
show the scene with his fucking tongue
in his mind the guy fucking fall and
whatever that guy died of AIDS in real
life they got him away there yeah the
guy is brilliant he just sits there and
you could see the rage you could feel it
bro I would go
crazy if I was the fucking well with
jail they had you and now you don't
understand the language some guys
selling you watered-down fucking tea
here at Sonya and now he killed your
friend's cat bro he throws a beatin on
that guy hits him with the pots the bans
and by the time he comes out from the
other side he's missing an eye and he
fucking grabs him he just bites his
fucking fuck awful good googly moogly I
was the fucking hate the seventh grade
bro that's the movies I was a little
fucking x-men that was a movie too that
taught a lot of kids not the fucking
smuggle drugs in the country because
there's a lot of people that watch that
locked up abroad and they're like well
the guys on TV now just he got away with
it
everything's fine most people that got
locked up abroad then didn't go so well
that Devers watch that show terrifying
fucking show
I don't even go there you don't watch
that show no no I don't even want to go
there mentally no I was never listen I
don't leave values that bad I got across
the border to Mexico try to bring them
over once that happens you're good
what's Mexico is not nearly as bad
crossing from Mexico into America that's
nothing like that my fears I don't
really well lead to cut you with drugs
well I do drugs I won't leave this
country because I need them I don't want
to get caught somewhere by sure you want
to smoke a joint in the fucking Africa
right yeah and who knows what the laws
are there
what's the laws for weed in China I'm
not good yeah lock you up they'll give
you 80 fucking years what is already
doing over there staying clean yeah yes
he's definitely staying clean general
Mao or whatever the fuck his name is
chairman chef what do they give you for
weed over there like what type of shit
they give you a weed enjoy but as far as
like sentence yeah I'm not good it's
very bad come on yeah the weed in China
is very bad weed North Korea's legal
nowhere that's weird
no bad in China they have listen yeah
the fucking listen that the mob stole
the idea from the people in China so I
know they're selling coke or something
not everybody's going to jail for 80
years in China let me pee real quick
drug laws in China let's look at how
illegal drug trade in China it's uh it's
pretty simple China has one fifth of
world's population
large and expanding economy while opium
has played an important role in the
country's history since the beginning Oh
since before the the First and Second
Opium Wars the 19th century China's
large loud matte loud large landmass
close proximity to the Golden Triangle
and numerous coastal cities with large
and modern port facilities make it an
attractive transit center for drug
trafficking hmm what is the fucking
opium war awesome let's go sounds like a
good movie the First Opium War okay
let's find out about the opium war
Dan was in the 1800's it was fought
between Great Britain and China over
there conflicting viewpoints on
diplomatic relations trade and the
administration of justice for foreign
nationals prior to the conflict Chinese
officials wish to end the spread of
opium and confiscated around 20,000
chests of opium approximately 1.2
million kilograms or 2 point whatever 8
6 6 million pounds from British traders
the British government although not
officially denying China's right to
control imports of the imports of the
drug objected to the seizure and used
its military power to enforce violent
redress so there's two two of them one
of them was in this the 1800's there and
another one was a 1856 to 1860 there's
two different opium wars while we know I
don't they give you a lot of time yeah
what's a drug seizure treaties and
conventions drug laws agencies okay
let's see drug law enforcement yeah
there's it's not good don't do drugs in
China
that's all right say remember um the
Mickey Rourke movie there's another
fuckin under under appreciated movie
you're the dragon tremendous 1385 dog
that was a great fuckin fuck yeah whoo
yeah cool we want my money when cuz what
the story was about basically what do
the Chinese say you know what bro how
long do you boil the fuckers gonna be
fuckin us in this they can't catch us
have you never read about the DEA
busting the Chinese smuggling heroin
yeah why is that really that brilliant
that they've been doing it for sister
beginning of time are they still doing
it in Chinatown I don't know I don't
know I heard it's a new work now but I
know when I was growing up the Chinese
gave it to the black guys the Chinese
supplied the Jews disciple a Chinese
supplied all the major outlets they
raped them they didn't give him that cut
they'd pay them a percentage wholesale
then they went out cut it 18 times and
on a $30,000 investment you made a half
a million dollars bro wasn't that a part
of that movie with Denzel Washington
where his friend was wasn't a part of it
was going to China and well he was take
he was bringing it for Vietnam Vietnam
but it was yeah with a shake or Liddy
all those motherfuckers right on it all
those motherfuckers we think they were
doing everything everybody want to go to
tour make tours of Vietnam they were
body bags the government do that that
was the CIA and all those heavy duties
right that's a cheek old lady got in
trouble well you got trouble for
Watergate mm-hmm but it's knowing that
he was over there said that he is back
and shit was well there was so much
money when you have so much money what
they the the amount of money in heroin
in the Vietnam era especially back then
there was no Wikipedia and no Edward
Snowden no Julian Assange you could hide
shit pretty fucking easy and there was
so much money to be made in heroin why
wouldn't the government make it there I
think their idea was like look we'd be
crazy like someone's gonna make this
money and if they make the money they're
gonna control the resources that they
get from that money they're gonna be
able to have influence and power and do
things to people with that money fuckin
will just do it we'll do it the right
way
and they just just started selling
heroin they just started doing it wait
the whole night I mean that was one of
the main reasons why we had a hard time
getting out of Vietnam the amount of
money that was being generated is that
the truth
oh yeah Vietnam and heroin is very well
documented the Vietnam trade in heroin
is a fascinating story because it's
essentially repeating itself in
Afghanistan nobody everybody buries
their head in the sand nobody wants to
admit it but the Afghanistan poppy trade
like the amount of heroin grown in
Afghanistan is a huge percentage of the
world's heroin not just a little bit of
Afghanistan money the world okay let's
look
what do you guess percentage of heroin
percentage of world heroin grown in
Afghanistan take a guess what would you
think it is 70% okay percentage of
world's heroin in Afghanistan I'm gonna
say ninety let's say okay shut up dude
okay let's let's find it is opium
production in Afghanistan Wikipedia
amounts to export value of four billion
dollars Wow holy shit wholesale correct
oh well I don't think you tax it
well that's wholesale is selling it to
me for an ounce or pound for whatever
and be cutting in meat if it's 4 billion
wholesale that they're the wholesalers
they grow it they process it I come over
and pick it up yeah I don't know I don't
know how they how they work it's just
amazing
ok fucking amazing mm-hmm
well it's one thing's a fact I'm having
a hard time finding numbers well one
thing is the fact that it's gone up well
they're all saying that it hits record
highs despite billions of dollars spent
to combat heroin trade Afghanistan opium
production hits record highs this is a
2013 the United States spent 7 billion
dollars to combat opium production so
they're they're stealing from both sides
they spent 17 billion dollars and it
went up it rose 36% Wow
oh my god that's hilarious 60,000 US
forces left Afghanistan down from a peak
of $100,000 so they're what they're
saying is essentially no matter what
they do the heroin production keeps
going up hmm weird it's hysterical who's
that act that just died tragically which
one the guy in New York all Walker
Philip Seymour from heroin after Philip
Seymour Hoffman they went and they said
well I was gonna go down this city some
fucking crazy commissioner and he was
and put a cop and they got the guy that
solved the bags and and then probably he
rolled on somebody
and once he rolled us
that fucking cop got transferred vo Pia
and that guy got fuckin thrown and
that's it
they can't go you know it's so fucking
big the heroin trade and one part of it
somebody normal who doesn't would say
yeah we're gonna fucking combat it
really really fucking heroin prices have
gone down 90% of the roads oh yeah
ninety by the percent in 2000 it was 70
heroin it's down to like you could buy
$7 bags of heroin bro the 7/7 hours I
could borrow $7 every fucking day guys
$7 how but you just how crazy that's
that's not but how crazy is it that one
spot 90% of the world supply the world
is 7 billion people how many people do
heroin in the world the numbers have to
be crazy when you add in all these other
countries not just America and in Mexico
add in North Canada add in everywhere
the whole world they process their own I
don't believe so they get the poppy from
there they process at Mexico cuz Mexican
heroin is that black car it's thick you
gotta shoot it the shit that you buy in
New York they have this white stuff you
could snort it
oh really and they tell you it's for
suburban kids that don't like needles Oh
snort Annette listen bro the heroin in
New York is a sold to Spanish people in
Puerto Ricans in the Bronx that down
that as black people that's what the New
York trade is wrong the heroin that sold
in New York is too fucking 20 year old
yuppies that do a blast they do they
don't shoot it they snort it that's
where the big heroin is so yeah you
still got the old geezers that a fuckin
shooting and their fucking will Seymour
Hoffman shoot it I mean yeah you should
have you have you tried the snorting it
went what's the what do you feel how do
you feel after I've never shot it I
stole his frame and the first time it
was I got sick I got really pukey and I
got sick but after I puked I felt better
and I got really high the first time I
did it was like a pass out type mode
like I I was thinking about stuff like I
was thinking about he was playing music
and I was thinking about stuff the
second time I did I was locked up
you did it in gentle gentle prison that
time I did it you came off a dude's but
don't know how'd it get in there
visitation oh you swap spit there was my
mouth head to the balloon I suppose good
with you whoa
not me I didn't smoke her a girl a girl
her wife cause it's not worth it and
that uh what that was was black tar
heroin and what the guy did was he
cooked it he poured it in my nose at
this arrangement that nothing happened
didn't work they're saying that 40% more
poppies are grown in Mexico than
marijuana now they're growing more
heroin 40% more than marijuana the
problem with the heroin the marijuana is
that it's legal here essentially
essentially legal in California
California is right next door so Lansing
is a nice people but they can't compete
with what the fuck is going on Northern
California they're very nice people or
Southern California that bro anywhere
there's still people in parts of the
country that smoke that brown wheat that
goes to Connecticut mm-hmm that goes to
Boston that goes to Minneapolis a lot of
brown weed there's still a little
traffic left in that brown tweed but for
the most part don't take no fucking
genius to know listen then fucking young
kids and oil in California they're about
to fucking blow up the world what
they're doing up there even after dams
like we can't compete build water dams
gone though hey you ever go to Amsterdam
why the fuck would I go to Amsterdam I
can go to Denver good good
it's all over gentlemen don't believe
the hype dish and they closed all the
stores Mike my stores down at the end of
the month the store next to his dealer
what do you mean defined wellness went
down all my favorite spots of why they
just showed down now they went after
landlords why would they do that why
would they do that they gotta pass it
just get it legal like it is in Denver
Denver is making so much money hand over
fist they did a CNBC show about it it's
incredible there was a guy was a weed
pen company says in two years his
company's gonna be worth a billion
dollars for fucking weed pens vape pens
out people buying vape pens with no
vapor to put it just to happen
Connecticut New York well you can have
legal yet you get wax now and stuff like
that you get wax you can grind the wheat
up there's a lot of them that you just
grind wheat up and you pack
but you gotta pack them every yeah like
every two or three hits you gotta pack
there those are silly but they have them
I'd like to see what would happen if
they take the legal marijuana thing to
Michigan and try to see you know throw
it in Detroit right yeah
let's good move but people get high and
then realize why the fuck we stayed in
Detroit was the first two month or the
first two months go to Kid Rock's house
people who have been robbed on the way
out yes that's the probably gonna happen
Detroit they don't have to hire too much
security because you know just you just
see if people parked a car and walk over
and I've seen in Hollywood there were
stories in Hollywood people were robbing
people outside of weed stores you know
now these weed stores that are getting
closed down the getting closed down by
the DEA like who's closing them down by
the city the city landlord what a place
I go you had a high an attorney so for
every day stays open he's gonna pay an
attorney to keep them open and they just
told me yesterday that the end of June
they're done Wow but there's still so
many stores so what are the rules where
stores are allowed to be open and not
open is it like you know proximity to
schools okay yeah I know that divine
wellness went down that was dead there
were the edible cakes divine wellness in
my eyes they always had something to
kill a motherfucker they had the capsule
dad auntie Dolores they had all the best
shit and they told me they were moved to
Canoga Park and this new company came in
because well they were moving because
they were 500 feet from the church
there's a church right on Lancashire so
divine wellness is moving in Canoga Park
they moved to Canoga Park and then some
other motherfucking gangstas came and
said fuck it you're gonna have to shut
us down I think it's the landlord in
there said so and they shut down and
reopened for like two days
now what they're what they and they will
walk so that would shut down the overall
services are the future I mean look at
San Diego they happen to San Diego it's
all tricky though guys get set up and
robbed
yeah yes you see what I'm doing right
now is I'm not smoking really man I do
the tubes in the morning
I quit the tube you know the vapor tubes
I got Girl Scout cookies of a man and
then by one o'clock I pop unedible you
know so I could buy a box of fucking
goobies mm-hmm I can have boobies or
Milo send me a box
you know that's the thing that I love
male director so as you send them to
copy you fucking license don't mail it
to me she knows me you know she knows
I'm legit so yeah I'm a big fan of the
edibles anywhere it's like better haha
up again so much I I sleep better I put
this different water and my sleep apnea
machine and now the edibles let me sleep
a lot better it's very nice and if you
wanted to stay constantly medicated you
could be very functioning with a small
dose of marijuana I saw some although I
fucked up last way I got high before I
keep punctured that's what that would be
great
no she even said something to me getting
high before yoga do you want to really
appreciate we get high before yoga
because you get high from yoga anyway
and if you get high and then do the yoga
it releases some crazy chemicals 45
minutes passes before you even though
you have like this not a hallucinogenic
trip you have a body trip mmm you start
focusing on your need and you can
actually feel the blood going into your
knee when you're high with the stretches
Yoga is really cool that's what they say
they do the hot yoga with weed right and
it really kicks it up I've never done
the hot yoga I don't know it's great now
you just bring water bring cold water
but the good thing about the hot yoga is
it really warms you up for stretching
because when you're cold it's very
difficult to stretch that's why I like
doing anything like real strenuous early
in the morning is tricky you got to
really make sure you warm up when I lift
weights in the morning a lot of times I
do I start my day by lifting weights I
take a lot take 20 minutes to warm up 20
whole minutes of like light kettle book
cleans like swings and cleans like light
body weight squats stretching touching
my toes moving around getting all the
blood flowing because you got to think
for eight hours or whatever you sleep
for you're just sitting there while
everything's just lying flat I mean your
Bloods pumping and everything like that
but there's no movement so everything's
kind of stiff and weird that's why when
you wake up your back herbs if you go to
bed for like two seconds and you lay
down your back doesn't hurt but when you
go to bed for eight hours you wake up
you like takes you a few minutes and
then whatever that stiffen it is it's
gone in half an hour so right it's gone
in a little while
got to warm the fuck up if you lift in
the morning
a lot of guys get hurt from that it's
one of the main sources of injuries is
early morning workouts you know that I
have friends that have 7:00 a.m. jujitsu
that sounds really cool at 9:00 a.m. -
Jitsu like fundamentals that sounds cool
but not for me
it's okay it's a longer warmup I like
11:30 11:00 I'm doing other things I've
walked around I think 9 o'clock my body
but I would have a heart attack I'm
really scared
well I have a big difference between
like if I have a kickboxing workout like
10:00 in the morning or a kickboxing
workout at 7:00 at night goddamn 7:00 at
night I'm on fire
my real better huh yeah really yeah I
like my shit over 11 o'clock 11 the wall
I've done 8 o'clock for me to do jujitsu
it is fucking brutal I'm out of here
you know even if I eat dinner at 4:00 I
can find no I gotta go like Friday at
7:00 I go to beginner jujitsu I hate it
for so there's no misunderstanding it's
exactly our ya know calisthenics we
practice a technique we roll for eight
minutes with a fuck out of it that's it
what do you eat before you workout
nothing he'll take nothing less I like
if I'm gonna do a long Jiu Jitsu I'll
take two
shrim tangent X but I don't do the
shroom text every time I like to space
it out I'll I could tell the difference
when I take a baby aspirin mmm then when
I taste you take I see a big fucking
difference right so if I'm gonna do
something long then I'll do the shroom
tech if I'm gonna do some way
kettlebells like just a short kettlebell
workout 10 sets of swings maybe three
cleans three sets of cleans and a
farmer's walk I just do a baby aspirin
and immediately a protein shake with
glutamine and then one and I eat shakers
300 calories I make them with water
right the force you should get a little
bit of sugar in there too a little bit
of natural sugar in your diet after a
workout yeah replenish your glycogen
your glucose you WOM eat some fruit
fruit is a good way to do it I do a lot
of fruit
yeah fruit juices with protein powder is
a good way to do it after a workout but
that's when you want to replenish like
within 30 minutes but before I like
fruit before I work out my favorite
thing to eat before I workout is either
oranges or pineapples because there's a
lot of fiber in them I feel like I've
eat like three or four oranges and then
have a good work
got an hour later there's no effects
like no cramping no weirdness easy to
digest
you know pineapples the same way I eat
like a nice bowl of pineapple like an
hour so before I work out I never
bothers me at all but you have the fibre
from the plant matter and you have
plenty of fuel you know plenty of sugar
in your body but natural sugar you know
but natural sugar you see when people
have sugar if you have sugar from a
candy bar or something like that that is
the most unnatural form of sugar that
human beings have ever created we
figured out how to isolate sugar take it
away from its natural plants natural
fruits and vegetables and then process
it and make it this weird thing that you
could just add to stuff in white powder
you know that white powder doesn't exist
in a wild and the effect that it has on
your body your body's like how are you
getting so much sugar in this fucking
thing do you have a drink you ever look
at like if you have just what you know
one of those powers those energy drinks
or uh you know post-workout drinks
hydration drinks look at the fuckin the
labels of those things look at a fruit
punch you all agree with drink fucking
Red Bull you guys ever see me drink a
Red Bull no you're not you'll have an
espresso every now and then after me I
like espresso after a meal too like Red
Bull
I don't like energy drinks I don't
believe have enough energy but it's the
sugar man the sugars and motherfuckers
weighs 75 grams of sugar and shit you
like that don't kill you that's terrible
for you like you know I can't even taste
a regular coke anymore it's horrific
syrup dud yeah shit a syrup do you ever
have that Mexican coke though there's a
burrito place in Hollywood that sells
those Mexican oh yea the bottles taste
better it tastes better still not good
for you yeah I drank enough soda for
three fucking bodies bro there's a great
documentary called King corn it talks
about the effect of corn on your body
and like how much corn they have like
how much of an influence corn has
because it's corn syrup is used in so
many different products it's a
fascinating thing we got to get back to
eating natural foods you know human
beings have gotten way off track we've
made some pretty yummy shit with corn
syrup and and sugars and things along
those lines but people want to be
healthy you got to get back to eating
healthy foods there's just no way around
it you got to eat salads you gotta eat
fruits and for most folks eating meat is
probably a pretty good idea eat some
healthy meats but these fucking the the
amount of power and the amount of
influence that lobbyists and and these
giant companies that that push corn
syrup and put corn syrup and everything
the amount of income that they make from
it like the the profit generated from
corn syrup is crazy corn syrup is in
like 90% of our snack foods if you look
around I just made that number up
completely a fan by the way but if you
look at like all the different snacks
and different things that have corn
syrup
it's fucking staggering it's off the
charts that's some terrible toxic shit
and it's everywhere but tastes great
they tricked you Joe Diaz they do trick
there's a dude who's making I should say
his name he's making all organic pot
candies now he came by here the other
day he's got a company called Scott like
jumbo yeah Jambo organic Jambo I got to
get you one of them they're fucking
fantastic so it's honey d-doesn't with
honey all organic ingredients no no high
fructose corn syrup no artificial sugars
no artificial sweeteners no artificial
flavors he's like the first guy to do
these organic pot candies and they're
great they're great not too strong
either they don't kill you they're like
half of Chiba Chu you know where you
don't get too nutty you'll probably take
four of them craziest Chiba true that is
so high demand there a month behind the
production associate they're making cash
sign - those little fucking helmet ones
Oh people means the CBDs but the damn
fucking little devil things really light
you up like they're really scary I got
people who have injuries if you have an
injury take a look a cheap achoo a half
a cheap achoo and then stretch out you'd
be amazed at how good you feel you feel
yours your muscles lengthening and
loosening up you feel things listen up
you need a half a decade you go to bed
you wake up feeling loose in the hash
cookies they don't happen people are
making there was one company who had a
in Hollywood
it was 20 bucks with two tiny cookies
but every time I hate those things dog a
hatchling I realized that it was Bruce
Lee it was even as easy because for the
for the stiffness in your joints is shit
I'm telling you when you eat and you
eerie fur it's two different worlds
Bruce Lee had some serious injuries he
had a serious back injury at one point
in time yeah injuries specifically for
the injuries well for medical marijuana
it's one of the number one things that
people use it for what's the fate Louis
CBDs yeah but the other one what star
the woman when you workout you eat
lettuce to take the acidity out of your
muscles that's what it says a THC when
you smoke it whatever you ingest it
whatever it takes to whatever are your
muscles after you worry lactic acid like
the gases information yeah there might
be a lot of bro science unfortunately
but Bryan Callen does Bryan can lay some
science on you and you know he's not
really scientist I do it all the time go
bro science is when you start reciting
shit that you heard online bro the
fucking the thing with THC it does is it
pulls the lactic acid and then you
google it and it doesn't do any such
thing that's bro side what is that a
blue ecig fuck Stephen Dorff you should
do that god damn commercials Joey Diaz
you you smoked that thing but you're
done completely with cigarettes for a
long time you don't worry about
relapsing back to cigarettes or sucking
on that no can you put that down you
can't how long you can go without one of
those three or four days no problem
you've done that before pockets you
loose
but isn't that win you lose I tell you I
like to always take at least one fruity
drink at the ice house I can't do that
no the ice house is great the
bartender's are great they're great the
waitresses are great you know man you
know you go to the ice house I can go
for a drink at the fuckin ice house when
I'm up there the other day I was craving
a beer for three days I walked around
craving a Budweiser cold
I crave cold Heineken
why do you have one do you have one
every now and then you don't like to
drink I forget I forget to stop and get
a beer so listen I will never ever drink
and drive like you want to see me flip
out let me have a drinking bit forced to
drive because I know I can't keep them
together in front of a cop and I know
that I could never I'll have to cop to
it
my God how to pay my drunken I drank a
drive like I would I'm totally against
all that shit right
I'll get stoned and fucking do ninety
down the 100 because I could handle it
but I can't handle alcohol well people
think that being drunk and being high
and driving a car are the same thing
there that's ignorant it's not true at
all you can smoke pot and do jiu-jitsu
with no problem whatsoever no problem
smoke pot and you're very coordinated
smoke pot and something drops you catch
it like your reflexes everything they're
all there unless you're not used to it
if you're not used to it all you're
thinking of starting getting high Joey
started making fun of me because we I
forget what we did we oh I remember we
went to the fucking Sunday brunch at the
House of Blues remember they had that
Gospel Brunch
in that gospel yeah we all went over
there and we were toasted to the gills
it was like one of the first weekend's I
ever got high and Joey Diaz like look at
this fucking rookie in case I was going
I can't believe a high I'm right now
this is ridiculous
I can't I'm I have to sit here I wasn't
used to it I didn't know how to deal
with it but if I was the same high right
now I'd be fine because I know what that
is it's a it's what you're doing is when
you're too high and you're paranoid and
you're frozen you're frozen cuz you
don't know what it is you don't know
what what comes next
well is this gonna get worse am I gonna
get more crazy oh my god how long is
it's gonna last but when you're used to
being high you're like I'm just high
dude relax everything's fine you know
what it is you know the worst it gets
you know the best it gets you felt the
full the full range of the effects but
you were laughing at me I'll never
forget we're gonna suck at rookie will
you first get high you
get so enjoyably hungry enjoyably like
this simple like a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich
it's fucking filet mignon in your mouth
yeah well I can you eat it with a bag of
chips
what heightens your senses right yeah it
just says it's so you don't even breathe
you just chew it like I have a bug
giggling like I love to giggle bro
a couple weeks ago I had a cookie and I
was sitting there so fucking stoned at 8
o'clock at night and I kept thinking to
myself this is the same cookie Casey
Kasem ate it was it was the week that he
was busy then he went missin thought I
felt so bad I grew up on fucking Casey
cases but then it was trafficking I was
watching the news that name there was
traveling on the 405 and I'm like oh my
god
this traveling of the 4 or 5 then Wilson
they said that the cause of the traffic
was that the President of Israel was on
the 405 so I walk after it down no I
kept thinking about was the President of
Israel knows about these cookies Casey
Kasem 8 he's coming to LA to get these
cookies that's how I was I kept giggling
at the thought of my thoughts
that's hilarious and I was happy I love
that I love still giggling that's what I
miss the most about being stoned to the
gills going to a diner and laughing at
the waitress just kidding how you doing
boy he just fucking you can't control
you so like I lists all that shit the
simple pleasures and week the simple
simple pleasures of being too well look
how many times we've been on the road
we'd be in the middle of nowhere
we're in some town and it's all of us
you know I was like you me red band re
and we'll get blasted and then we'll go
somewhere and have a giggle fest like
especially when it's all of us you know
we have a good group of like two or
three of us and we go somewhere on the
road and you get really high in some
town it's like we're all in other
together you know really sitting in
Starbucks or eating lunch somewhere you
or Joey Diaz go we're all stoned and
we're trying to get the GPS working and
Joyce has no town that was when Joe Joey
used to have when you are at your
heaviest
it used to have food Mel
downs when you would land you'd have to
eat right away anxiety I was but it
wasn't that remember we're in Austin you
were yelling because we were trying to
find some place it wasn't the sugar it
was I just wanted to get to my room and
fucking figure out how I was but you
were eating we went someplace I was a
door blowing the daytime I didn't have
time to ride around listen when I get
off the fucking plane I got this time
you ain't got this time with me how
would you set that up did you have like
a network yeah people would you get the
time just talk about on stage but I mean
you like say if you were gonna fly into
Austin like say if you needed you needed
coke did you already know people that
you get coke from nobody would land
really oh you call it we're gonna come
see you and that was code for we're
bringing it ah
so I knew but I didn't know at that time
at Austin I just still to this day I
have flight anxiety when I get off a
plane I got time to dilly-dally I don't
want to walk I don't want to talk I want
to get to the room let me go upstairs
let me take a shit I'll be check-in let
me relax and then we'll do whatever the
fuck you want to do forget the fucking
GPS we should have got a car with a
driver that's the hotel ain't got time
to land at four o'clock the fucking
going to traffic with GPS till this day
I dread landing at LAX after 12:00
we'll do it I'm going back to Austin I'm
doing the I'm actually doing a comedy
club this time because I'm preparing for
my comedy special so I'm doing cap city
for the first time in years I haven't
done cap city in fucking the 15th and
the 16th I can't wait
yeah how happy am I gonna be I can't
wait I love that place and I you know I
love doing the theater there last time I
did Austin City lemon said it to me when
I was doing this yeah I'm fucking pumped
I mean I like mixing it up man that is a
great old real comedy club I really
enjoyed myself there I refused to and
now the last four times I've been there
I love them there's no better staff
there's no better time like Margie I
like the Doubletree I like that now they
put you in a new hotel
it's fucking funky Rishi no more
Doubletree daya downtown
shit they rebuilt downtown you somewhere
else and it was really interesting but
the double cheese across Papa Papa Papa
dos Papa does papacito's was around the
corner yeah right up the street right up
the fucking water both of them
Fuddruckers Fuddruckers yeah that's
right
apparently you got it we don't but you
gotta fuck with this there's there's
some barbecue joints in Austin right now
that are so off the charts ari said
there was a line for a three hours three
out hey wait for three hours look my mom
left Cuba listen play wait oh yeah you
could pay guys nine thousand our way
don't worry don't twenty I know that but
guess what what I don't don't we should
stay away for three hours of food I
think they should stay now on and I
think when you get to the front of line
text me and I'll fucking show up and
I'll give you a hundred bucks no no no
they drive it to you Joe they try to
drive it that's not good because then by
the time it gets you it's not hot
anymore plus you want to get it have
those figures of like brisket yeah you
don't want that you want to get it right
when the guy pulls it off of the meat
like boom puts it on a plate you want to
be there while that all goes down
Anthony Bourdain waited in line just
like everybody else I forget the name of
the place I want to say Franklin source
uh yeah well we're almost out of time
here
I love you Biff I love you to your
mother fun best cuz I gotta take a water
of the way out take whatever you want to
say take one of the c2o coconut waters
c2o started sponsoring fighters I was
watching RFA the other day some dude has
c2o coconut water on his shorts so
salute - you see - oh thank you sir
awesome - fuckin this delicious coconut
water - if you don't like coconut water
try c2o because it's all with Thai
coconuts Thai coconuts is a short plants
like the Tom Cruise of coconuts it's
only five feet tall and they're super
delicious it's like a sweet sort it
almost feel like they add sugar but they
don't just how it tastes
that's right you can even have they even
have some of the pulp if you like that
chewy shit yeah I like it sometime I
like without pulp the best but I like I
don't pass on the pulp once I use that I
see - oh and a lot of mixed drinks it's
great for a mixer yeah I would imagine
right hydrate at the same time you
hydrate yeah so I got a couple clubs
coming up in July I'm doing wise guys in
Salt Lake homes
shit 18th and the 19th oh shit almost
sold out already then i'm doing san jose
performing arts theater on 26th one do
that oh shit you know buckle up what are
you doing in reno some club I don't
believe a pretty good I'm doing American
comedy company in San Diego to the 8th
and the 9th the first with you yes the
first ace ace Theatre in LA that is
August first me Joey Diaz and Duncan
Trussell Sark act and then August we
haven't finalized it but it will be in
Denver Colorado it will be at the Comedy
Works and that's where I'm gonna be
doing my next Comedy Central special and
I'm fuckin very excited about this my my
favorite all-time shit that I'm putting
together I can't wait I'm real geared up
right now I'm enjoying the shit out of
it if you want to go see the funniest
motherfucker on earth you go see Joey
motherfucking Diaz Joey Diaz you could
get them at woods the railroad
next Friday is Saturday at the Ice House
if you're local July 10th through 12th
of the San Jose improv up definitely
Gracie Nationals the regionals I'll be
uh and then that next week I'm at the
South Pointe casino and then the 25th of
the 26 I think I'm gonna read over it
doesn't get any better you fuckheads
gather Brian you got anything going on
going over we got kill Tony this Friday
Joe Rogan and Dahmer era and then kind
of nice house this time ten o'clock Ice
House have your comics come at 9 o'clock
sign up I was a Comic Con 2014 July 23rd
and 24th good lord
Florida August with Sam Tripoli three
days it's all good Lord that's my new
thing
good lord that's from the jungle bro be
careful you might summon spirits that's
real that's a real rattle okay
we gotta get the fuck out of here thanks
to nature box thanks to
naturebox.com/tyler box calm slash Rogen
and save 50% off your first box thanks
also to tango to Rogan tang calm save 25
bucks off your first device tonight
ice house Ian Edwards bra
Callen Sam Tripoli Tony H cliff and me
you Fox we love you and you love
yourself